ich darf dann auch die letzten
Fotografen Kamera Leute bitten sich
hinzusetzen
ja der Teil sitzt ja schon
ich begrüße Sie ganz herzlich an diesem
Dienstagmorgen zur Bunde in der
Bundespressekonferenz dieser
Pressekonferenz zu den Reformvorschlägen
der Regierungskommission
Krankenhausversorgung dazu begrüße ich
den Bundesminister für Gesundheit
Professor Dr Karl herzlich willkommen
ich begrüße Professor Dr Schorr den
Koordinator der Regierungskommission
Krankenhausversorgung ich begrüße
Professor
christianistische Intensivmedizin und
Notfallmedizin noch länger
und ich begrüße Irmtraut Gürkan die
stefanten Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender und
herzlich Willkommen wir haben uns einmal
der Minister beginnt
vielen Dank dass wir hier wieder unter
ihre Ladung Tagen dürfen da sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wir widmen
uns heute den Problemen in den
Krankenhäusern die Krankenhäuser haben
gravierende Probleme das sieht man
derzeit auch in der Situation in den
Kinderklinik das ist nur exemplarisch
für das was das krankenhaussystem
aktuell insgesamt erleidet das
Hauptproblem das steht seit vielen
Jahren fest ist dass wir fast alles an
Budget im Krankenhaus und über
sogenannte Fallpauschalen bezahlen
farbpauschalen sind einheitliche
pauschalen die für vergleichbare Fälle
bezahlt werden egal wie aufwendig der
Fall jetzt behandelt wird und egal wo er
behandelt wird ob er gut behandelt wird
aber nicht so gut behandelt wird alles
wird überfallpauschalen reguliert und
damit
dominiert die Ökonomie im
Gesundheitssystem besonders im
krankenhaussystem dahingehend wenn ich
immer das gleiche Geld bekomme für den
Fall dann mache ich gewinnen indem ich
den Wahl möglichst billig behandelt wird
somit lohnt sich eine billige Behandlung
des Falles denn wenn der Preis immer der
gleiche ist dann mache ich gewinnen wenn
ich den Fall billiger behandelt somit
hat man mit diesem System eine Tendenz
zu billiger Medizin zum zweiten die
Krankenhäuser können nur das Budge
erhöhen indem sie mehr Fälle waren dann
und das gibt einen starken Anreiz immer
mehr Fälle zu behandeln diese Fälle
werden aber dann zur Kostenkontrolle
schlechter bezahlt somit kommen die
Krankenhäuser durch dieses System in ein
Hamsterrad sie müssen immer so billig
wie möglich behandeln und so viel wie
möglich behandeln das ist eine Art der
Ökonomie die in dieser Art in Europa
nicht ein zweites Mal praktiziert wird
das Problem ist hat mindestens zehn
Jahren bekannt und es ist bisher nie
grundsätzlich also angegangen worden
daher ist die Reform die wir jetzt hier
in Auftrag gegeben haben an der wir
jetzt Arbeiten aus meiner Sicht eine
Revolution im System war dieser Anreise
über die Fälle das Budget aufzubauen die
Fälle möglichst billig zu behandeln das
soll abgestellt werden die Vorschläge
werden gleich von der Kommission
vorgestellt die Kommission arbeitet seit
mehr als einem halben Jahr in unserem
Auftrag an diesen Reform Vorschlägen das
ist ein Schwerpunkt meiner Arbeit auch
für die nächsten paar Jahre die große
Reform des krankenhaussystems wir haben
schon erste Schritte getan wenn man so
ein System hat wo es sich also lohnt
viele Fälle zu machen und möglichst
billig die Fälle zu erbringen dann würde
man erwarten dass Bereiche wie
Kindermedizin Geburtshilfe oder auch die
Pflege vernachlässigt werden genau das
haben wir gesehen da sind die ersten
Reformen die wir jetzt schnell gemacht
haben wenn man so wird notfallreformen
Reformen für die Kinderheilkunde da
haben wir die entbudgetierung schon
vorgenommen am letzten Freitag in der
Kräuter 80 bis 100 Prozent Geburtshilfe
haben wir eine Reform gemacht und die
Pflege ist ebenfalls entlastet worden
das sind die Bereiche wo wir
notfallmäßig jetzt gefordert das gemacht
haben aber die große Reform muss jetzt
kommen die wird heute vorgestellt der
wichtigste Punkt ist der aus der
Perspektive des Patienten was hört sich
denn da ändern zum einen die Menschen
können sich dann darauf verlassen dass
die Krankenhäuser die wirklich gebraucht
werden zum Beispiel auf den ländlichen
Gebieten also in den Stadtteilen wo es
wenig dafür sorgen gibt dass diese
Krankenhäuser auch überleben können ohne
dass sie immer mehr Fälle behandeln
müssen somit wird die Sicherheit der
Krankenhäuser dargestellt abgesichert
die von der versorgungsperspektive ja
betrachtet für die Patienten unbedingt
notwendig sind das zweite was sich für
den Patienten ändert und das sehr
wichtig wenn er behandelt wird kann er
sicher sein dass ökonomische Aspekte
keine dominierende Rolle spielen also
man wird nicht so behandelt wie es der
klinikgewinn Macht sondern wie es
Medizin nicht notwendig ist die Medizin
wird wieder in den Vordergrund der
Therapie gestellt und folgt nicht der
Ökonomie und zum dritten also wenn man
Spezial Eingriffe benötigt schwierige
Eingriffe dann kann man sich auch darauf
verlassen dass die dort erbracht werden
wo sie besonders gut erbracht werden
können war dort die Kosten gut abgedeckt
sind die Krankenhäuser müssen da nicht
auf jeden Euro schauen sind für diese
Spezial Eingriffe dann auch gut
ausgestattet personell aber auch von
Material her von den Geräten her und von
der Investition her somit im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes eine osmaner Sicht
Revolution im Krankenhaus Sekt ein
Revolution die wir unbedingt benötigen
und auch etwas was dazu beitragen wird
dass die Personalprobleme in den
Krankenhäusern besser werden und zwar
deshalb derzeit verlassen viele
Pflegekräfte aber auch viele Ärztinnen
und Ärzte die verlassen die
Krankenhäuser weil sie diesen
ökonomischen Druck nicht ertragen wollen
die Arbeit macht vielen ich bin ja mit
vielen Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch im
Gespräch keinen Spaß mehr ich kenne
sogar leider in der Ärzte die mit mir
gemeinsam studiert haben die jetzt die
Krankenhäuser verlassen haben und in der
Praxis arbeiten weil sie sagen dieser
ökonomische Druck das möchte ich einfach
nicht mehr und wir werden damit mit
einer neuen Ausrichtung der Bezahlung
werden wir auch dazu kommen dass mehr
Menschen in dem System bleiben wollen
denn wir werden die Babyboomer sonst
nicht versorgen können so mit einer
größere Form ich bedanke mich bei der
Arbeit ich bedanke mich für die Arbeit
bei der Kommission insbesondere auch bei
Professor die Kommission geleitet hat
aber auch bei janitis und bei Frau
görkern das war eine tolle Arbeit mehr
als 50 Sitzungen viele Sitzungen habe
ich selbst erleben dürfen und ich weiß
dass dort mit großem Sachverstand aber
großem Elan gearbeitet wurde und wir
werden das auf jeden Fall
berücksichtigen also ich kann jetzt
schon sagen dass diese Vorschläge die
wir heute hören werden die werden die
Grundlage auch für die nächsten
politischen Reformschritte für uns als
Ministerium sein vielen Dank Herr
Minister
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die Krise
des krankenhaussystems in Deutschland
hat sich in den letzten Monaten noch
einmal dramatisch zugespitzt täglich
erreichen die Regierungskommission
Berichte von gesperrten Abteilungen und
Notaufnahmen aufgrund von Überbelegung
und fehlenden Personal die Patientinnen
und Patienten können nicht aufgenommen
werden oder müssen in weit entfernte
Krankenhäuser verlegt werden das
Krankenhauspersonal ist massiv
überlastet die Regierungskommission hat
extrem ernst genommen das ist lichterloh
brennt
dieses inakzeptabel insbesondere der
Deutschland im europäischen Vergleich
mit 13,1% des Bruttoinlandsproduktes
eigentlich viel Geld für die
Gesundheitsversorgung ausgibt und
bezogen auf die Einwohner hat
Deutschland auch eher
überdurchschnittlich viel medizinisches
Personal
Personal und Geld werden aber durch das
Hamsterrad des gegenwärtigen die Systems
aufgezählt wir haben 50% mehr
Krankenhausbetten und 50% mehr
Krankenhausbehandlungen als unsere
europäischen Nachbarn was die hohen
Kosten und den hohen Personalbedarf
zumindest zum Teil erklärt
nach unserem gegenwärtigen System werden
die Krankenhäuser wie wir gehört haben
nur dann bezahlt wenn Sie einen
Patienten behandeln einen Fall wie man
es dann ökonomisch ausdrückt auf solche
Fallpauschalen setzen zwar viele
Gesundheitssysteme aber nirgends wurden
die Fallpauschalen so gründlich und so
ausschließlich zur
Finanzierungsgrundlage gemacht wie in
Deutschland
auch aus meiner eigenen Jahrzehnte lang
Arbeit im täglich im Krankenhaus kann
ich bestätigen die von der
Geschäftsführung von Jahr zu Jahr
steigende Zahlen gefordert werden dieses
sich immer schneller drehende Hamsterrad
wird durch die Logik des diad-systems
und auch durch unverhältnismäßige
Gewinnerwartung von
krankenhausbetreibern bedingt mit
anderen Worten wir haben masse statt
Klasse und wir müssen die Schere
zwischen Unterversorgung und
Überversorgung schließen und dann
Versorgung wie sie derzeit z.B in der
Kinderheilkunde sichtbar wird und
Überversorgung aufgrund falscher
ökonomischer Anreize
auch haben wir schlicht nicht mehr die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter um
Behandlungen mit fragwürdiger Indikation
durchzuführen der Personalmangel der
betrifft die Krankenhäuser dreifach die
Babyboomer beginnen in Rente zu gehen
Krankenhäuser haben weil sie ein 24
Stunden Betrieb sind ein besonders hohen
Personalbedarf und die älter werden in
Babyboomer sind die Patienten von morgen
so kann es nicht weitergehen als Leiter
und Koordinator der Regierungskommission
Krankenhäuser muss ich ja klar
feststellen dass die
Krankenhausversorgung kollabieren wird
mit katastrophalen Konsequenzen wenn wir
jetzt nicht grundlegend reformieren
die tiefgreifende Reform die wir heute
hier präsentieren wurde in einem extrem
intensiven wissenschaftlichen
Arbeitsprozess von den 17 Expertinnen
und Experten der Regierungskommission
ausgearbeitet wir wurden erst im Mai
berufen und können heute diese zentralen
Empfehlung vorlegen nachdem wir bereits
zuvor ja zwei Stellungnahmen zu anderen
Themen veröffentlicht hatten wie Sie
wissen kommen die Mitglieder
insbesondere aus dem Bereichen Medizin
pflegeökonomie und recht
unsere Empfehlung werden erarbeitet auf
der basiswissenschaftlicher Erkenntnis
der Fakten und der Daten und wir sind
dabei vollkommen unabhängig sowohl von
der Politik einschließlich des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums als auch
von Verbänden und Organisationen die
ihre Interessen vertreten
mit der heute hier vorgestellten Reform
soll die überökonomisierung beendet
werden medizinische nicht ökonomische
Gründe sollen für das Handeln von
Krankenhäusern im Vordergrund stehen
heute macht die Regierungskommission
einen ersten grundlegenden Vorschlag zur
Umgestaltung des Krankenhauswesens in
Deutschland dem zeitnah weitere wichtige
Empfehlungen der Regierungskommission
folgen werden
wir schlagen vor die Krankenhäuser zu
einem relevanten Teil dafür zu bezahlen
dass sie Teil der Daseinsvorsorge sind
weil es ist jetzt hier zum Beispiel ein
Kamera Stativ auf den Schädel fallen
sollte sind wir doch alle froh dass es
hier in der Umgebung exzellente
Krankenhäuser mit hochkompetenten
Personal und der erforderlichen
Ausstattung gibt und wenn das
hoffentlich nicht passiert umso besser
aber die Krankenhäuser haben ja trotzdem
eine Leistung eine sogenannte vorhalte
Leistung gebracht und diese muss
zukünftig auch bezahlt werden die
Fallpauschalen andererseits sollen
entsprechend Absinken so wird auch der
ökonomische anreizbehandlungen lediglich
um der Behandlungen wählen durchzuführen
gesenkt
wir empfehlen ferner Krankenhäuser drei
verschiedenen klar definierten Stufen
zuzuordnen damit Deutschland einheitlich
eine Planung nach dem Bedürfnissen der
Bevölkerung möglich wird je nach Stufe
lokal regional oder überregional
und Krankenhäuser sollen ihre
Aufgabengebiete nicht mehr so ungenau
zugewiesen bekommen wie es bislang mit
den klassischen medizinischen Fächern
erfolgt sondern zielgenauer mit klar
definierten Vorgaben die ein Krankenhaus
erfüllen muss etwa hinsichtlich Personal
oder medizinischen Geräten möchte in ein
Beispiel geben Innere Medizin zum
Beispiel ist extrem breit
und unspezifisch und ermöglicht dass
auch eine kleine und schlecht
ausgestattete Innere Abteilung vom
akuten Herzinfarkt bis zur komplexen
Krebsbehandlung alles durchführen und
abrechnen kann die neuen
Leistungsgruppen die wir vorschlagen zum
Beispiel wäre das dann Leukämie und
Lymphome garantieren zukünftig dass alle
Patienten und Patienten nur noch in
Abteilung behandelt werden die hierfür
die nötige Expertise und die nötige
Ausstattung haben hierdurch soll
Qualität und nicht wie bisher vor allem
Quantität sichergestellt werden
ich habe von drei Stufen oder Leveln
gesprochen den Krankenhäusern der
untersten Stufe 1 kommt eine
herausragende Bedeutung zu weshalb die
Regierungskommission für diese eine
besondere Rolle vorsieht sie stellen
flächendeckend die Versorgung sicher da
wo die Menschen wohnen sie sollen
teilweise integriert Arbeiten ambulant
stationär sie sollen regional geplant
werden unter Beteiligung neben den
Ländern der Regionen oder Kommunen und
der niedergelassenen Ärztinnen und Ärzte
vor Ort es soll gesetzgeberisch
ermöglicht werden dass sie von
qualifizierten Pflegefachpersonen und
nicht zwingen von Ärzten geleitet werden
können und sie sollen diese
Krankenhäuser der ersten Stufe
vollständig aus dem viagi-system
herausgelöst werden meine beiden
Kollegen aus der Kommission Frau Gürkan
und Professor karadianidis werden unser
Empfehlungen gleich noch weiter
erläutern
abschließend ist es mir noch ein großes
Bedürfnis meinen
kommissionskolleginnen und Kollegen für
die großartige professionelle intensive
und auch im übrigen ehrenamtlicher
Arbeit und für ihr übergroßes Engagement
von Herzen zu danken zusätzlicher dank
oder besondere Dank gebührt den
professorenides Busse und August als
besonderer Motor dieser Reformvorschläge
vorangebracht haben und ihnen für ihr
Interesse am Thema vielen Dank
ja vielen Dank guten Morgen zusammen ich
will Ihnen
kurz skizzieren was so die Grundpfeiler
unseres reformvorschlages sind und Herr
pschor hat es schon angedeutet und
möchte vorneweg auch nach dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister danken es ist
schon was besonderes dass wir in dieser
Kommission wissenschaftlich wirklich
völlig frei entscheiden dürfen das ist
etwas ganz Besonderes wir hatten keine
politischen Vorgaben bei diesem Modell
wie wir es entwickelt haben
das konnte allein aus dem entstehen was
auch wir gelernt haben was in den
letzten 20 Jahren falsch gelaufen ist
und ich möchte das noch mal besonders
betonen das ist wirklich etwas
besonderes bei der wissenschaftlichen
Arbeit in einer solchen Kommission
wenn Sie ein Konzept erarbeiten dann
fällt das nicht vom Himmel sondern sie
brauchen ein paar Grundprinzipien und es
ist eben schon angeklungen dass wir im
Moment in diesen DLG System was bedeutet
dass sie im Großen und Ganzen für einen
Fall bezahlt werden und je mehr Technik
sie reinstecken je mehr Personal sie
reinstecken desto besser ist es in der
Regel auch vergütet um das vielleicht
meinen einfachen Worten zu erklären
bedeutet auch dass die Kliniken sehr
stark von Mengen abhängig waren und das
heißt ein Grundprinzip muss natürlich
sein dass man diese starke
mengenabhängigkeit und diesen starken
Leistungsbezug reduziert das alleine
würde aber nicht ausreichen die wirklich
gravierenden Probleme in unserem System
zu lösen ein zweites großes Problem dass
wir haben ist die extrem heterogene
Qualität in der deutschen
Krankenhauslandschaft und deswegen ist
es unabdingbar dass wenn sie sowas
einführen wie Vorhaltung ich komme da
gleich noch zu dass sie das auch knüpfen
an gewisse mindeststruktur
Voraussetzungen damit auch jede
Patientin und jeder Patientin in
Deutschland weiß wenn er in Köln ein
Krankenhaus geht was ein bestimmtes
Label trägt dass die gleiche
Mindestqualität erfüllt wie hier in
Berlin oder im Bayerischen Wald das ist
extrem wichtig und ist auch ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt für uns in der
Kommission für die Mindestqualität die
jeder Patient erhalten sollte
das Konzept eröffnet auch erstmalig in
meinen Augen die echte integrierte
Ambulanz stationäre Zusammenarbeit das
ist ein Punkt der über viele Jahre
hinweg gefördert gefördert wurden ist
wir haben ihn adressiert in unserem
Modell genauso nehmen wir aber auch sehr
ernst dass die Bevölkerung eine
wohnortnahe pflegerische Versorgung
wünscht sie wissen alle dass wir relativ
gesehen auf die krankenhausstandorte zu
wenig Personal haben und das bedeutet
wenn ich auf der einen Seite wohnortnah
akute und gute akutpflegerische
Versorgung haben will verschiedene
Krankenhaus Level dann brauche ich eine
grundreform damit ich das mit dem
Personal stammen den ich im Moment zur
Verfügung habe auch wirklich machen kann
der letzte Punkt gerade noch mal der
jetzigen Diskussion die Kommission
eröffnet auch die Möglichkeit dass wir
die Kinder und Jugendmedizin besser
vergüten weil sie einfach insgesamt ein
höheren Personalbedarf hat und wir das
Wahrnehmen dass man mehr Personal
braucht für eine Leistung die im
Erwachsenenbereich vielleicht einfacher
zu erbringen ist deswegen besteht das
Grundkonzept aus drei Standbeinen die
auch eng miteinander verknüpft sind das
ist einmal die Einführung der
einheitlichen krankenhauslevel und das
bedeutet eine sehr klare und auch harte
mindeststrukturqualität in Deutschland
an allen Stellen in diesem Land das
bedeutet die Einführung der
Leistungsgruppen und das bedeutet die
Einhaltung der Vorhaltung Vorhaltung
kann man sich vorstellen so ähnlich wie
bei der Feuerwehr das alleine eine
Daseinsvorsorge da ist
lassen Sie mich kurz auf die Vorhaltung
eingehen im Moment ist es so dass sie
für eine Leistung zu 100% vergütet
werden die chemission schlägt jetzt vor
dass dieser Anteil der so extrem stark
mengenabhängig ist deutlich reduziert
wird und um diese vorhaltekomponente
ergänzt wird wir schlagen vor dass diese
Vorhaltung über alle Leistungsgruppen
das sind insgesamt 128 die wir
ausgearbeitet haben mit ungefähr 40
Prozent gesetzt wird mit der Ausnahme
der Intensivmedizin Notfallmedizin
Neonatologie und Geburtshilfe da
schlagen wir vor dass der vorhalteanteil
höher gesetzt wird auf
60%, weil es einfach den Charakter der
Fächern näher kommt und die Vorhaltung
erfordert
wir waren in davor dass man die
Vorhaltung zu hoch setzt es braucht eine
gewisse Ökonomie im System wir haben
auch Vorteile im diad-system die sollten
wir nicht ganz verkennen und wenn wir
dahin kommen dass wir so etwas haben wie
das Selbstkosten deckungsprinzip dann
haben wir die gleichen Probleme die wir
im Moment im DRG-System haben nur ein
paar Jahre später und deswegen ist diese
40 60 dieser Vorschlag vielleicht der
goldene Mittelweg den wir haben ich
hatte eben schon mal gesagt dass alleine
würde nicht ausreichen um die Probleme
zu lösen deswegen schlägt die Kommission
vor dass wir diese Vorhaltung verteilen
über die Leistungsgruppen und über die
Krankenhaus Level Krankenhaus Level
sollen zukünftig in 123 eingeteilt
werden drei ist das was sie als
Grundversorger kennen und drei als das
was sie als Maximalversorger kennen und
besonders wichtig ist uns dabei das
Level 1 also das was die Bevölkerung
direkt und kurz erreichen kann und das
soll in Zukunft einge vielleicht werden
ihren Level 1 i und in ein Level 1 n
bedeutet Sie müssen eine Notaufnahme
vorhalten nach der Definition des
Gemeinsamen Bundesausschusses in der
Stufe 1 und i soll bedeuten integriert
Ambulanz stationäre Zentren und das ist
der Weg dahin dass wir endlich dazu
kommen dass der niedergelassenen Bereich
mit dem Krankenhaus zusammenarbeitet wir
stellen uns das so vor dass sie im
Zentrum eine akutpflegerische Leitung
haben mit akutpflegebetten und schlagen
durchaus auch vor dass qualifizierte
Pflegefachpersonen eine solche Einheit
leiten nicht zwingend Ärzte dass sie
niedergelassen die Möglichkeiten haben
dieses Bett zu belegen und ihre
ärztliche Leistung nach EBM abzurechnen
dass sie auf der anderen Seite aber auch
die Möglichkeit haben dass das
Krankenhaus fest Ärzte anstellt glaube
das ist ein wirklich modernes Konzept
was eine gute akutpflegerische
Versorgung der Bevölkerung gewährleistet
es ist uns auch wichtig insbesondere in
der deutlich engeren Vernetzung der
Kliniken die in Zukunft telemedizinisch
miteinander verknüpft sein sollen und
zwar sowohl in der Zuweisung zum Zentrum
als auch dann danach Zurückverlegung und
heimatnamenversorgung und deswegen ist
sowas wie der Sozialdienst auch
unabdingbare Voraussetzung für jedes
Krankenhaus und sie finden das sehr
dezidiert in den
mindeststrukturqualitäten
zum Abschluss wir profitiert in unserem
System profitiert der Patient davon dass
er in Zukunft dem richtigen Angebot auch
zugeführt wird was sich sehr stark auf
Qualität stützt das bedeutet wenn ich
eine Krebserkrankung habe dann muss man
zukünftig auch in einem zertifizierten
onkologischen Zentrum behandelt werden
wenn ich eine eckmotherapie brauche dann
darf das in Zukunft nicht mehr jedes
Krankenhaus machen sondern dann dürfen
es nur noch die Krankenhäuser machen die
dafür auch wirklich qualifiziert sind
und das bedeutet dass in erster Linie
die Qualität für den Patienten im
Vordergrund steht
Krankenhäuser profitieren weil sie die
Möglichkeit bekommen in Zukunft enger
zusammen zu arbeiten sie können
Leistungsgruppen untereinander tauschen
sie können ihr Level ab oder downgraden
weil sie jetzt genau wissen was ein
Level ist ja das bietet unglaubliche
Möglichkeiten auf dem Krankenhausmarkt
und den Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern bietet die Möglichkeit dass
ökonomische Druck aus dem System endlich
rausgenommen wird aber noch mal es ist
nicht ganz ohne Ökonomie zu machen weil
sonst die Kosten im Gesundheitssystem
explodieren würden glauben sie mir zum
Abschluss noch ein persönliches Wort wir
haben in den letzten 20 Jahren Fehler
gemacht auf allen Seiten dass das
Hamsterrad so schnell läuft wie Herr
Schorr das vorhin beschrieben hat das
liegt auch daran dass wir Mediziner das
befeuert haben
wir haben alle Fehler gemacht wir haben
extreme Partikularinteressen auch auf
Seiten der Stakeholder im
Gesundheitswesen und ich wünsche mir
sehr dass der Tag heute zu einer Zäsur
wird weil dieser Tanker Gesundheitswesen
insbesondere Krankenhäuser ist in
extreme Schieflage geraten und ich
glaube es ist wirklich der allerletzte
Zeitpunkt dass wir noch die Möglichkeit
haben das Ruder rumzureißen aber wir
müssen ein Stück weit jetzt runter von
diesen extremen partikular Interessen
die wir haben und alle zusammenarbeiten
sonst kennt das Schiff noch in den 20er
Jahren vielen dank vielen Dank
ja nach diesem dramatischen Appell von
großer karikalität möchte ich gerne noch
mal auf dem auf den Grundkonsens in der
Regierungskommission zu sprechen kommen
die Kommission war sich sehr einig dass
eine reine Leistungs- und
mengenorientierte Vergütung nicht mit
dem Auftrag der Krankenhäuser als
wesentliche Elemente der Daseinsvorsorge
vereinbar ist wir haben alle die lange
schon in dem System arbeiten damals mit
großer Hoffnung auf die DLCs gesetzt die
diadies
2002/2003 eingeführt
Deutschland war nicht das erste Land
sondern wir hatten Anleihe genommen an
Australien an den USA an einigen anderen
europäischen Ländern und hatten und
davon einen Leistungsbezug eine faire
Vergütung haben
erwartet und das ist auch in großen Stil
zunächst eingeführt worden auch die Diag
wir sind ja ständig verfeinert worden
von ursprünglich mal 650 dann auch über
1200 eigies aber wir haben bei dieser
Entwicklung
schon nicht ausführlich und nicht
sorgfältig genug bedacht auch in den
Krankenhäusern dass wir auch eine
Daseinsvorsorge im Sinne einer
vorhaltefinanzierung
brauchen wir sind immer über den
mengeneffekt gegangen und haben damit
einiges kompensiert was man bei Lichte
betrachte heute sagen muss wir sind zu
sehr in die Menge gegangen und haben zu
wenig auf die
Notwendigkeit der
vorhalteversorgung und
eingerichtet und dazu gehört auch zu
überlegen was kann ambulant gemacht
werden auch im Krankenhaus was muss
stationär gemacht werden sondern wir
haben dem stationären Bereich den Vorzug
gegeben und das muss ich nach
40 Jahren Erfahrung in Unikliniken schon
auch sagen dass Primat der Medizin ist
etwas ins Hintertreffen geraten und
deswegen war ich persönlich auch sehr
froh dass dieses diese Korrektur mit in
der Kommission im großen Stil
vereinbart wurde und wir uns da alle
sehr sehr einig sind was bedeutet nun
die Abkehr von dem reinen diage-modell
wir werden ein zwei Säulen
Finanzierungsmodell haben und die zweite
Säule ist eine ganz relevante weil sie
ganz wesentlich
den Aspekt der Daseinsvorsorge von
Krankenhäusern auch beinhaltet
das geht nicht und top auch das muss man
der Klarheit wegen sagen sondern wir
werden das
Gesamtbudget dass wir heute haben um
verteilen es wird wir haben es gehört
zwischen 40 und 60%
in ein vorhaltebudget um orientiert
werden
umgeleitet werden und der
Leistungsbezug und der mengenbezug
bleibt bei den abgesenkten Tier cheese
mit ca 60% wobei wir uns auch einig
waren es gibt Bereiche innerhalb der
Krankenhäuser da ist der die Planbarkeit
nicht gegeben da ist der vorhaltebezug
umso wichtiger möchte das Beispiel noch
mal aufgreifen Neonatologie
Geburtshilfe die Bereiche können wir
nicht planen anders sieht es aber zum
Beispiel in der Orthopädie aus die
Orthopädie hat sehr viele elektive
Leistungen da kann man auch die
Kapazitäten ganz anders planen und für
die Bereiche in die die Planbarkeit
eingeschränkt ist da soll das Budget bis
zu 60% betragen wobei auch das ist eben
schon mal erwähnt worden in diesem
vorhaltebudget auch mit ca 20% des
Pflege Budget enthalten
ist das heißt das pflegebudget so wie es
bislang
finanziert wurde über die als Zusatz zu
den DRGs soll auch so
weiterentwickelt werden weiter
finanziert werden während das
verbleibende vorhaltbudget nicht über
die Tiere ausgezahlt werden soll sondern
über einen Finanzierung über das
Bundesamt für soziale Sicherung auf der
Basis der den Krankenhäusern zugeordnet
werden Level und Leistungsgruppen
Einteilung das ist eine Aufgabe die den
Ländern obliegen wird sicher mit
Unterstützung des Medizinischen Dienstes
die die Eingruppierung auch bestätigen
bzw evaluieren sollten wir werden nicht
von heute auf morgen umstellen sondern
so wie seinerzeit auch sich gut ähm gute
Erfahrungen gemacht wurde mit einer
Konvergenzphase sehen wir jetzt auch für
diese Umstellung in das zwei
säulen-modell eine fünfjährige
Konvergenzphase vor
Ausgangsbasis werden die Jahre 22 und 23
sein in denen sich zunächst die
Nomenklatur ändert aber die Finanzen
zu null Prozent im vorhaltebudget und zu
80 Prozent im
diaggi-budgets sein würden und 20
Prozent im pflege-budget also so wirken
der Staaten und dann in fünf Jahren
entsprechend um orientieren in ein
vorhaltebudget zwischen 60 und zwischen
40 und 60%
wenn ich mir die Diskussion der letzten
Jahre so noch mal in Erinnerung rufe wir
wussten die Insider im Krankenhaus aber
ich würde mal sagen im Gesundheitswesen
insgesamt wussten dass das System so wie
wir es immer weiter verfeinert haben
immer noch ein paar diaggis ausgereizt
und und neu
kalkuliert dass dieses System auf Dauer
nicht tragfähig ist aber wir hatten
nicht die Kraft oder auch nicht die
Konsequenz es
bei Zeiten einen Stopp zu sagen und zu
sagen wir müssen jetzt auch uns noch mal
besinnen was ist die Aufgabe der Auftrag
der Krankenhäuser nämlich da seins
versorge in einem ganz ganz wesentlichen
Bereich das Beispiel mit der Feuerwehr
schon gefallen auch die Feuerwehr wird
nicht danach den Einsätzen bezahlt
sondern sie wird dafür bezahlt dass sie
da ist und wenn sie gebraucht wird ganz
schnell und und
gezielt ihren Ihren Auftrag nachgeht und
das ist das was man von den
Krankenhäusern auch erwarten kann
erwarten muss dass sie sei es in der
Notfallversorgung sei es in der
Geburtshilfe sei es bei bei Erkrankungen
bei komplexen Erkrankungen
qualitätsorientiert die Leistung
erbringen und vielleicht noch ein
letztes Wort zu dem was wir heute in dem
Konzept noch nicht alles drin haben es
wird weiter in der Kommission gearbeitet
wir werden uns mit dem Thema der
qualitätsorientierten
Implementierung der Vergütungsstrukturen
weiter befassen das betrifft nicht nur
die Strukturqualität die haben ja jetzt
drin bei der Zuordnung der Level sondern
vor allen Dingen die Prozesse und
Ergebnisqualität wir werden uns sicher
auch in Abstimmung mit den Ländern über
die in die Finanzierung der
investitionsbedarfe der Krankenhäuser
[Musik]
dann ersetzen müssen denn das was wir
hier Ihnen heute präsentieren betrifft
im Bereich der Betriebskosten die wie
gesagt aufgeteilt werden sollen künftig
in einen vorhaltebudget und ein
leistungsabhängiges mengenbudget das
heißt die abgesenkten dlgs es gibt eine
riesen Chance auch den shift ins
ambulante in dem Krankenhaus zu machen
sie kennen ja das aus der letzten aus
dem letzten Konzept
dankenswerterweise ist das Gesetz letzte
Woche am Freitag ja verabschiedet worden
dass wir künftig auch im Krankenhaus die
tagesstationären Behandlungen
einführen können wir werden eine
Erprobungsphase haben aber für mich ist
es wichtig dass wir das was in anderen
Ländern schon lange unterwegs ist wo man
gute Erfahrungen gemacht hat dass wir
uns auch in Deutschland trauen auch
diese Schritte zu gehen und in dem Sinne
wird auch uns ähm dieses Grundkonzept
viele viele Chancen ermöglichen und ich
bin mir sicher dass die Krankenhäuser
darauf gewartet haben und es zügig auch
umsetzen wollen
vielen Dank wir kommen jetzt zu ihren
Fragen weil mich schon erreicht hat dass
einige Fragen vielleicht nicht direkt
mit der Krankenhausversorgung bitte ich
die nachher nachrangig zu stellen
möglicherweise hat der Minister die ein
oder andere Frage noch eine Antwort und
wir fangen an mit ihren Fragen
vorspielkermann wie kann man ZDF ich
höre auch jetzt also auch fein von
medizinischer Seite viel Selbstkritik
also dass dieses System aus dem Ruder
gelaufen ist
Herr Lauterbach sie sagen das waren
jetzt sie sagen 20 Jahre die nicht gut
gelaufen sind sie sagen zehn Jahre wo
sehen Sie denn die politische
Verantwortung geht das in Richtung
Vorgänger oder sagen Sie als Experte
sind sie auch sozusagen mit beteiligt an
einer Situation die jetzt sehr sehr
schwierig ist keine Differenz sondern
das System ist seit 20 Jahren eingeführt
und diejenigen die es damals eingeführt
haben ich war auch beteiligt haben
damals schon gesagt also dieser 100%
Ansatz dass man nur über Fahrzeugschein
bezahlt der ist sehr gefährlich Moment
war auch von den damaligen Gutachtern
nicht gewünscht wir hatten damals zum
Beispiel für die Universitätskliniken
schon ein anderes System vorgeschlagen
ist aber damals nicht umgesetzt worden
da sind die ursprünglichen Probleme
immer bekannt gewesen sie haben aber
erst seit zehn Jahren wirklich dazu
geführt dass dann Ökonomie immer stärker
nach vorne gerückt ist Herr stark also
zugespitzt aber korrekt aus gedrückt zu
sagen ist mir auch die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit denen ich zusammen studiert
habe mit denen ich zur Schule gegangen
sind die jetzt leitende Ärzte sind es
wird immer mehr darauf geschaut wie
viele Fälle sind noch drin bei dir also
wie viele Fälle kann man jetzt noch
machen wie viele Knie können noch
operiert werden kann man die
Leistungssteigerung also im Bereich der
Hüftgelenks also Endoprothesen kann man
dann noch was machen geht dann noch
etwas das heißt ökonomische Druck wird
auf der Seite ich habe sehr intensiv
empfunden dort gibt es zum Teil auch
Vereinbarungen höheres Gehalt wenn wir
Fälle gemacht werden können und dann
kann der einzelne Patient ja nie sicher
sein
ob sein eigener Eingriff jetzt also
einem ökonomischen Motiv folgt oder bis
medizinisch notwendig wurde und das
haben wir seit zehn Jahren zunehmend das
muss dringend beseitigt werden und die
Reform ist lange notwendig einen ersten
Schritt haben wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode schon gemacht indem
wir die Pflege aus dem
fahrzeugscheinsystem entfernt haben das
war damals mein Vorschlag in dem
Koalitionsverhandlungen habe ich noch
mit dem damaligen
ja Verhandlung für Brühe verhandelte der
Frau Minister gewesen ist die Pflege ist
schon raus aber kindergrunde
Geburtshilfe in allen anderen Bereichen
es geht nach wie vor somit diese Reform
ist dringend notwendig und ich schaue
nach vorne und gebe niemandem nach
hinten die Schuld
sie sagten auch also es wird operiert
nach ökonomischen Kriterien gibt es eine
Vorstellung wie viele unnötige
Operationen aufgrund dieses ökonomischen
Drucks durchgeführt wurden
das ist nie wirklich wissenschaftlich
untersucht worden weil dazu müssten sie
ja quasi
die in der Medizin gibt es für viele
Eingriffe eine Grauzone ich bringe ein
Beispiel bei also einer Krebsbehandlung
wo abzusehen ist dass es Risiko für den
Patienten sehr hoch ist es gibt eine
kleine Wahrscheinlichkeit dass er noch
überlebt und dann machen wir sehr häufig
mehr als man bei den eigenen Verwandten
oder auch bei sich selbst machen würde
das wird beschrieben das ganz klar und
das jetzt also in Studien zu untersuchen
ist sehr schwierig aber wir haben hier
eine also Ausdehnung in die Menge und
wir wissen dass wir zum Beispiel sehr
gewagte Eingriffe und sehr aufwendige
Eingriffe auch bei Patienten durchführen
am Lebensende oder wahrscheinlicher
Gewinn gering ist
dann machen wir in der Mitarbeiter
ja ich habe zwei Fragen die eine drängt
sich ja förmlich auszuqualität also uns
wurde jetzt 20 Jahre erzählt dass die
diadies das Beste seit geschnitten Brot
sind
ich erinnere mich an diverse Gutachten
keine blutigen Entlassung und
dergleichen mehr ja das gab es ja alles
durchaus wie groß ist überhaupt der
Vertrauensverlust das würde ich sie
jetzt vielleicht direkt mal fragen wenn
nach ökonomischen Prinzipien gehandelt
wurde wir sehen jetzt gerade alle Ops
wurden verschoben in zwei Jahren
Pandemie man fragt sich ernsthaft werden
die nachgeholt waren die unnötig wie
sollen die nachgeholt werden wenn das
jetzt schon sich wieder staut also da
gibt's glaube ich ein ganz großes
Vertrauensproblem und dann hätte ich
noch eine Frage zu den Leistungsgruppen
vielleicht dazu noch
inwiefern und wann werden im
regulatorischen Prozess der Festlegung
der Leistungsgruppen und Ihre
Anforderungen die Beteiligten also die
Länder die Partner der Selbstverwaltung
auf Bundesebene Pflege
Gesundheitsfachberufe und so weiter
regelhaft eingebunden und vielleicht
auch noch Qualität in der Medizin dafür
gab es auch ein tolles Institut das
iq-ticket drei Fragen ja das Ecotec hat
meiner Meinung nach nichts gebracht in
den ganzen Jahren hat an Qualität nicht
nach vorgebracht außer Bürokratie
brauchen wir das weiter auch nach dieser
Reform danke
vielleicht will ich mal anfangen ich
glaube zu den politischen Prozess muss
der Bundesgesundheitsminister
Gleichstellung nehmen wie sich wie er
sich das vorstellt auch in der
Einbindung der Verbände das ist ein sehr
sehr wichtiger Punkt grundsätzlich haben
wir einen sehr hohes Vertrauen der
Bevölkerung in die Medizin und ich halte
das auch trotz der Fehlleitung die wir
in den letzten 10 20 Jahren hatten für
gerechtfertigt
sie müssen wenn sie sich angucken wo
sind die Probleme in Systemen ist es
immer sehr gut den OECD-Vergleich zu
nehmen oder den europäischen Vergleich
und dann sehen sie an einigen Stellen in
unseren System das was Frau Spiekermann
eben auch gefragt hatte haben wir
natürlich gewisse Leistungen wie zum
Beispiel die hüfttepp-implantation oder
rückenoperationen oder die Implantation
von Herzklappen über die Leiste da sind
wir internationaler Spitzenreiter mit
unglaublicheren steigerungszahlen die
wir jetzt immer noch haben und trotz der
Pandemie haben wenn ich so ein
Benchmarking habe mit den anderen
Ländern der Welt insbesondere mit
vergleichbaren Gesundheitssystemen dann
sieht man dass Deutschland an der ein
oder anderen Stelle sicherlich zur
Übertherapie neigt zum Teil ökonomisch
bedingt aber auch uns noch mal
selbstkritisch zu sagen auch wir
Mediziner führen ja diese Therapie durch
ja auch wir sind ein Teil des Problems
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir
jetzt aber die Schere dass die
Unterversorgung insbesondere mit den
Messungen die nicht so gut vergütet sind
immer größer wird ja wir sehen das ganz
stark jetzt im Kinder- und Jugendbereich
wir sehen das aber auch in der
Versorgung des älteren dementen
Patienten als Beispiel ja der keine
Intervention braucht der im System immer
weiter nach unten fällt und ich glaube
unsere Aufgabe ist jetzt und deswegen
versuchen wir mit diesem Reformkonzept
jetzt auch ein Vorschlag vorzulegen dass
diese Schere aus über Versorgung und
Unterversorgung deutlich geringer wird
und alleine die Einführung von
Vorhaltung nimmt den Anreiz immer mehr
und immer mehr zu machen
ja vielen Dank sie haben eine sehr
wichtige Frage gestellt wie groß ist der
Vertrauensverlust hier muss man zunächst
einmal sagen das was in der Klinik
gemacht wird ist zum allergrößten Zeilen
medizinisch notwendig und so wird gut
gebracht aber es ist trotzdem so der
Druck auf die Ärztinnen und Ärzten auf
das Pflegepersonal hier ökonomisch zu
handeln ist groß und darf nicht
verschwiegen werden das aber darf nicht
den Eindruck erwecken als wenn hier
skrupellos gehandelt ich hatte eben
schon gesagt es gibt Grauzone macht man
den Eingriff noch macht man ihn nicht
und wir haben definitiv ein
Qualitätsproblem die beiden Bereiche die
beispielsweise eben erwähnt hat die Eco
Versorgung da haben wir in Deutschland
eine breite Struktur aber leider sind
bei uns während der Pandemie relativ
gesprochen mehr Menschen an der Ecke nur
Versorgung gestorben als in
beispielsweise Frankreich
weil die Versorgung wurde preiswert
gemacht an vielen Plätzen daher hatten
wir eine Sterblichkeit von 70 Prozent
anderswo wurden 50 Prozent erreicht es
gab auch Zentren die haben 35 Prozent
erreicht somit haben wir ECMO gemacht
sehr aufwendig aber es sind viele Leute
gestorben sehr teuer an vielen Plätzen
gemacht aber eben nicht die Top-Qualität
wir haben es gemacht sind mehr Leute
gestorben und so ist es auch bei der
Krebsbehandlung eine sehr gute Studie
der Deutschen Krebsgesellschaft hat
gezeigt diejenigen die Auswahl der
gegebenen gleichen Krebsbehandlung in
zertifizierten Krebszentren behandelt
werden haben eine bessere Sterblichkeit
leben länger überleben häufiger die
vielen die nicht in diesen Zentren also
behandelt werden
nicht sterben wahrscheinlicher das sind
Tatsachen darauf müssen wir mit dieser
Reform reagieren jeder gibt das beste
aber wenn ich die Spezialisten nicht
habe und die Geräte nicht habe und die
Erfahrung nicht habe kann ich einfach
nicht so gut sein weder bei ecmode noch
bei der Krebsbehandlung und das muss
ehrlich benannt werden und da müssen wir
jetzt reagieren wir arbeiten jetzt sehr
eng mit den Verbänden zusammen aber ich
will folgendes sagen ich bin der
Kommission dankbar die Kommission hat ja
hier ehrenamtlich mit sehr hoher
Qualität und total Vertraulichkeit
gearbeitet ohne Störung durch das
Gesundheitsministerium und auch ohne
Störung durch die Lobbygruppen als wir
diese Kommission gemacht haben da sofort
Geister da kommt nie was raus wo sind
denn die Krankenkassen die damit machen
wieso ist die Krankenhausgesellschaft
nicht dabei wieso sind da nicht von
Anfang an die Länder beteiligt hätten
wir das von Anfang an gemacht hätten wir
heute nichts vor zu zeigen kein Ergebnis
wir haben immer wieder und ist auch
nichts herausgekommen niemand sagt dass
das dlc-system das beste System ist das
habe ich in Deutschland seit 15 Jahren
nicht mehr gehört sondern das war
einfach immer so dass wir dieses System
hat diese Probleme das bekommen wir aber
nie geändert weil die Lobbygruppen zu
stark sind das war der Grund und wir
machen jetzt hier eine Reform wo wir
wirklich auf das was gemacht werden soll
keine Rücksicht auf die Lobbygruppe
nehmen wenn Lobbygruppen wichtige
inhaltliche Argumente haben dann werden
die berücksichtigt aber es wird keine
Rolle spielen was zum Beispiel einzelne
Verbände denken oder was passen denken
oder was meinetwegen private Träger
denken es sei denn es ist wirklich ein
inhaltlicher Punkt aber Lobbygruppen
haben bisher keinen Einfluss auf die
Entwicklung des Konzeptes gab und sie
werden definitiv auch keinen Einfluss
auf die Umsetzung auf die politische
Umsetzung haben
sie sprechen ja von der Revolution
wo ist denn jetzt die Revolution also
das fallpauschalsystem bleibt ja dann
doch irgendwie bestehen es wird ja nur
reduziert bzw
abgesenkt und nicht wie sie sich
gewünscht haben überwunden und der
karaganinis
sie hatten ja das Vorbild Feuerwehr
benannt private feuerwehrkonzerne gibt
es nicht in Deutschland dagegen gibt es
aber private Krankenhauskonzerne werden
die nach ihren Vorschlägen bestehen
bleiben können
zunächst einmal für die Kliniken die der
Stufe 1 angehören das sind ja die
Kliniken die vor Ort die Versorgung
vorhalten müssen die die Daseinsvorsorge
in der Fläche vorhanden auf dem Land und
so weiter und so fort da werden die
Fahrt euch an gar keine Rolle spielen
die bekommen schlicht und ergreifend
also Tag des pauschalen und dort also
haben wir gar keine Versprechen zum
zweiten selbst in der Spitzen Medizin
ist es dann so dass 40% und also in der
Notfallversorgung 60 Prozent der
Vergütung also kommt ohne dass er einen
einzigen fahren behandeln müssen
somit also gibt es hier eine
vorhaltepauschale die also den
ökonomischen Druck komplett rausnimmt ob
ich dann einfach mehr oder weniger mache
ist gar nicht so relevant weil wenn ich
den Fall mehr mache habe ich etwas
höhere Kosten aber ich bekomme auch nur
ein wenig mehr Geld das hält sich das
Gleichgewicht somit bin ich aus diese
Mechanik heraus Gewinne zu machen heraus
ich kann nicht durch einen zusätzlichen
Fall für den ich nur 60 Prozent der
Pauschale bekommen kann ich keinen
Gewinn machen somit Fall also das bleibt
an ökonomische Anreiz aber alleine über
die fallsteigerung kann keiner mehr
Gewinne machen die fallsteigung führt
nicht mehr zu gewinnen und die
vorhautpauschale kann ich nicht zu
gewinnen Erbringung nutzen somit auf den
zweiten Teil Ihrer Frage zurückzukommen
natürlich ist dieses System für private
Träger deutlich weniger interessant
weil somit die Möglichkeit über die
fallsteigerung und über die
Ökonomisierung der Leistung Gewinne zu
machen geht drastisch zurück das ist
richtig aber das ist eben ein Preis
einer solchen Reform oder das
medizinische stärker in den Vordergrund
rückt ich glaube dass dieses System dazu
führt dass ein großer Teil der
Versorgung plus minus null
wirtschaftlich ausgeht aber dass man
nicht mehr im Hamsterrad ist
vielleicht zwei Punkte dazu die
Feuerwehr ist natürlich nicht ganz
hundertprozentig mir im Krankenhaus zu
vergleichen auch wenn ich das Beispiel
so genannt habe weil es immer so
plastisch ist wir haben natürlich schon
auch Bereichen Gesundheitswesen die nach
anderen Kriterien arbeiten was mir aber
ganz wichtig ist wenn sie solche
Konzepte machen und solche Modelle dann
spielt Gerechtigkeit
ganz ganz hohen Stellenwert und deswegen
ist es in unserem Modell auch so dass
gleiche Leistung immer gleich bezahlt
wird wenn Sie eine Leistung haben die
ein Level 1 Krankenhaus erbringen kann
also eine einfache basismaßnahme und
diese Leistung ein Level 3 Krankenhaus
oder die Universitätsklinik erbringen
kann dann muss diese gleiche Leistung
auch weiterhin gleich bezahlt werden und
das gleiche gilt auch für die
trägerlandschaft in Deutschland wenn sie
solche Konzepte machen dann dürfen sie
die nicht ausrichten auf einzelne Träger
sondern dann müssen Sie diesen
gerechtigkeitsgrundsatz wirklich
zwingend einhalten natürlich ist die
Möglichkeit
Gewinne abzuschöpfen aus dem Krankenhaus
singt deutlich aber aus dem Klinikalltag
heraus darf ich Ihnen sagen Gewinne zu
machen im Krankenhaus mit der Situation
die wir im Moment haben wird extrem
schwierig werden in den nächsten Jahren
da habe ich mir Sorge im ambulanten
Bereich wo jetzt Hedgefonds hergehen und
Praxen aufkaufen ja das macht mir das
ist mir ein wirkliches Dorn im Auge ja
dass wir im niedergelassenen Bereich
plötzlich Hedgefonds haben die
einsteigen da sollten wir uns viel mehr
drauf konzentrieren auch in der Zukunft
aber Gewinne machen so wie das in den
letzten Jahren erlebt haben wird extrem
schwierig selbst in unserem Modell
ich würde gerne Herrn pschor eine Frage
stellen zur finanziellen Gesamtwirkung
dieser Reform die gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung zahlen ja jetzt
glaube ich ungefähr 85 Milliarden Euro
pro Jahr es klang eben schon mal ein
bisschen an aber ist diese Reform ein
Nullsummenspiel also kommt man mit
diesem Geld aus oder
bleibt da nicht doch einen Rest von
höherem auch Druck auf diesen nicht
vorhalte Teil der Leistungen vielleicht
können Sie das erklären ja gute Frage
die wir in der Regierungskommission auch
sehr intensiv diskutiert haben und wir
sind da ganz klar zu der Überzeugung
gekommen dass das keine zusätzlichen
Kosten verursacht warum nicht weil eben
durch die Minderung des Anreizes auf die
Menge auch Behandlungen die gar nicht
nötig sind eingespart werden das spart
dann auch Kosten weil Behandlungen
ambulant erbracht werden können die
heute zu hören Preisen vollstationär
erbracht werden können denken sie anders
Level 1 i was integriert stationär
ambulant behandeln soll bis jetzt ist es
ja so von
in vielen komplizierten kleinen
Ausnahmen abgesehen des Krankenhäuser
nur dann abbrechen können wenn sie die
Patienten auch ins Bett legen und
übernachten lassen und dann wird es
teuer und die Gesamtsumme das ist ganz
klar unsere Empfehlung soll gleich
bleiben und nicht steigen
eine ganz kurze Ergänzung zu Kinder und
Jugendmedizin bei insbesondere mir auch
so wichtig ist wir wissen alle dass die
dass der personalansatz da besonders
hoch ist und deswegen gibt es in unserem
Konzept eine Möglichkeit dass die
Politik ein voraufliegt der die
Möglichkeit bietet dass die Kinder und
Jugendmedizin ein bis zu 20 prozentigen
Aufschlag bekommt auf das was sie an
Gesamtvolumen hat das ist uns besonders
wichtig weil Kinder einen hohen
Stellenwert in unserer Gesellschaft
haben weil wir gerade sehen dass die
Kinder und Jugendmedizin extrem leidet
weil da die Kapazitäten schon deutlich
weiter runtergegangen sind als im
Erwachsenenbereich das heißt das bildet
die einzige Ausnahme wo man diesen
Strukturform dann aber auch theoretisch
befüllen muss
zusätzlich kleinen Zusatz Herr Minister
würden sie sich das zu eigen machen dass
das Geld was jetzt da ist reicht oder
brauchen Sie eigentlich mehr für den
Krankenhausbereich
zunächst die Investitionskosten sind
nicht ausreichend abgedeckt hier sind
die Länder in der Pflicht und kommen
dieser Pflicht nicht ausreichend nach
dass es auch an sehr wichtiges Problem
das muss so gelöst werden und zum Zeiten
ich glaube dass wir langfristig auf
jeden Fall mehr Geld ausgeben werden im
Krankenhaussektor weil die Babyboomer
Generation jetzt also in das Alter
hineinkommt wo mehr Leistung benötigt
werden und die Medizin wird besser die
Medizin wird teurer und besser aber im
Vordergrund steht jetzt erstmal eine
effiziente Struktur und diese effiziente
Struktur wird mit dieser Reform
geschaffen werden und es ist auf keinen
Fall möglich die Probleme die wir jetzt
haben allein mit mir Geld zu lösen das
einfach schlicht nicht möglich für die
ineffiziente Struktur wie die die wir
derzeit haben haben wir weder das
notwendige Geld noch das notwendige
Personal
ein paar die Hauptstadtstudio eine Frage
an Sie Herrn Lauterbach sie wurden ja
schon angesprochen auf die
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern NRW hat
er ja eine Vorreiterrolle geht da schon
neue Wege bei der Krankenhausplanung da
hatte Herr lauman gesagt er hat sich
schon Leistungsgruppen überlegt das
könnte sein dass die nicht mit den
Leistungsgruppen die sie sich heute
überlegt haben übereinstimmen ähm wie
soll das gelöst werden dass das System
mit den Ländern wirklich in Einklang
gebracht werden kann was sie hier heute
vorschlagen und eine Frage an Sie Herr
Professor karagierides könnten sie noch
mal ganz einfach erklären welche
Krankenhäuser aus den der die ähm
Fallpauschalen rausfallen sollen und
welche Voraussetzungen die dafür aber
erfüllen müssen danke
ja zunächst zu den Ländern ich habe die
grobe Struktur dieser Reform den Ländern
aus der auf der also besonders
Ministerkonferenz gestern schon einmal
kurz vorgestellt ohne dass ich die
Lösungsvorschläge detailliert
vorgestellt hätte die Länder wissen dass
wir in einer solchen Reform arbeiten die
Länder wissen dass eine solche Reform
notwendig ist und einiges von dem was
zum Beispiel in Nordrhein-Westfalen
gemacht worden ist oder auch in
Niedersachsen
ist hier also sei mal zu sehen als die
Bemühungen in diese Richtung sich zu
bewegen aber das aus unserer Sicht nicht
radikal genug das heißt also die
Vorschläge in NRW oder in Niedersachsen
sind richtig aber sind nicht wirklich
ehrgeizig genug um diese riesigen
Probleme lösen zu können wir werden mit
den Ländern unseren Vorschlag im
detailiert sprechen und dafür steht auch
schon der Termin das wird am 5 Januar
sein dort wird es eine große Besprechung
mit allen Ländern aber auch den
Fraktionen
Deutschen Bundestages geben wo die
Kommission und wir als
Bundesgesundheitsministerium dran die
Umsetzung dieser Pläne erstmaligen
ja als Kölner darf ich vielleicht noch
hinzufügen dass ich gerade glaube dass
unser Konzept und das nrw-konzept sehr
gut zur Deckung zu bringen sind und ich
glaube sogar dass NRW unser Konzept
braucht um seine Ideen durchzusetzen wir
haben glaube ich jetzt schon ein
gebahnten weg und das ist sehr gut was
Nordrhein-Westfalen gemacht hat und ich
glaube mit unserer Hilfe kann die
Krankenhaus Landschaft gerade eben
schwierigen Regionen wie bei uns glaube
ich deutlich konsolidiert werden die
Bevölkerung trotzdem sehr gut versorgt
werden wer soll vollständig rausgenommen
werden aus dem wir dieses hin das ist
eine ganz wichtige Frage bei den extrem
vielen Krankenhäusern die wir in
Deutschland haben haben wir gesagt diese
Level 1 Kliniken werden eingeteilt in E
und n und n bedeut bedeutet
Notfallversorgung bedeutet 24/7 dass
jemand da sein muss das heißt das ganze
bleibt in der Vorhaltung und bleibt in
dem residual die System so heißt es er
dir die bleibt es in dem System drin die
anderen Kliniken die kleiner sind und
die sich auf die akutpflegerische
Versorgung bezieht da soll auch wirklich
die Pflege im Vordergrund stehen und
deswegen werden die vollständig
rausgenommen aus diesem Vergütungssystem
und in Zukunft bezahlt werden über
sogenannte sachgerecht kalkulierte
degressive Tagespauschalen das sind
Tagespauschalen die hatten wir schon vor
Einführung des dlg-systems die sollen
abbilden dass die pflegerische
Versorgung im Vordergrund steht sie
müssen degressiv sein damit auch ein
gewisser Anreiz entsteht dass man nicht
wochenlang Patienten auf den Betten
liegen hat das hatten wir vor
einführungs-
dass dann vorhanden ist und die
ärztliche Leistung wird abgerechnet über
das EWM System so wie wir das aus
niedergelassenen
Kollegen hier in der Mitte hier vorne
welches wollen sie das Mikrofon benutzen
ja Herr Minister ich hätte noch mal zwei
Fragen an Sie einmal die Frage
welche gestaltende Rolle kommt noch den
Fraktionen zu haben die sich bereit
erklärt praktisch die Vorschläge der
Kommission zu übernehmen oder könnten
die sozusagen auch noch ganz in eine
andere Reform Richtung gehen und die
zweite Frage ist
wenn sie die Rolle der Selbstverwaltung
also ich habe das Wort Selbstverwaltung
in dem ganzen Konzept überhaupt nicht
gefunden
so negieren wird dann das ganze auch in
einer staatliche Finanzierung gesteuert
oder wird der werden wird dieses
Krankenversicherungssystem so wie wir
das haben noch erhalten bleiben
ja vielen Dank in der Tat wir haben auch
die Fraktionen
der Ampel der fortschrittskoalition
gestern vorab informiert die Ampel
Koalitionär sind daher also was die
Problemanalyse angeht im Bilde und
kennen auch die ungefähre Richtung
unserer Form Details wäre natürlich dann
am 05.01 besprochen und ich glaube dass
wir hier uns einigen werden wie es auch
also funktioniert hat bei den
Vorschlägen die wir am Freitag
beschlossen haben die Vorschläge
Kinderheilkunde Reform Geburtshilfe
Reform
tagesstationäre Versorgung und Hybrid
die das waren ja auch vier Vorschläge
die aus der Regierungskommission
Krankenhäuser gekommen waren die wir
dann mit den Fraktionen mehr oder
weniger eins zu eins auch in relativ
kurzer Zeit beschlossen haben und ich
kann mir vorstellen dass wir auch also
was diese große Reformen angeht in
ähnlicher Geschwindigkeit und in
ähnliche Konvergenz hier mit dem
Fraktionen klarkommen werden wir binden
die Fraktionen sehr eng ein in das dass
wir hier machen das gilt aber auch für
die Länder somit bin ich da sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir ein Konzept auf
dieser Grundlage nicht eins zu eins aber
auf dieser Grundlage gemeinsam
entwickeln werden zum zweiten natürlich
die selbsterwartung bleibt also genau
das was sie ist die Selbstverwaltung
setzte diese Vorschläge um meine also
Ausführungen Ebenen Bezug auf die
Bedeutung von Lobbygruppen also er hat
ja nichts mit der Tatsache zu tun dass
wir ein selbst erwartetes System haben
die Krankenhausgesellschaft die also
Krankenkassen alle sind angehört worden
bei der Entwicklung der Reform und alle
werden bei der Umsetzung voll
eingebunden sein also wir bleiben genau
bei dem System nur die Spielregeln
werden verändert diejenigen die spielen
werden nicht ausgetauscht
okay bestellen wir das noch mal zurück
hier sind die Wand
Lauterbach noch mal eine Frage zur
Beteiligung der Länder sie sind ja
darauf angewiesen dass die Länder
mitspielen weil sie ja nur als
Bundesgesundheitsminister dann nur
begrenzte Durchgriffsrechte sozusagen
haben die Krankenhausplanung des
Ländersache also wie wollen sie die
Länder dazu bringen tatsächlich dann
mitzuziehen und die zweite Frage ist was
Geld ist ja schon gesprochen worden aber
vielleicht können Sie uns mal eine
Vorstellung geben wo vielleicht die
Kranken auslandschaft in zehn Jahren
steht also wir haben jetzt 2000 Kliniken
etwa 500.000 Betten ähm wie in welcher
Größenordnung werden wir uns dann
bewegen
zunächst das was wir hier gehört haben
hat nichts mit der Krankenhausplanung zu
tun sondern das sind Vorschläge zur
Krankenhaus Vergütung und die
Krankenhausplanung ist alleine
Ländersache die fassen wir nicht an also
es bleibt dabei dass die
Krankenhausplanung zu 100% Aufgabe der
Länder bleibt und die durch die
Reformvorschläge weder angesprochen noch
überflüssig gemacht worden noch
irgendetwas das hier geht es nur um die
Vergütung also wie wird bezahlt über
DRGs oder über ein solches System wo
eben Vorhaltekosten Qualität
Erreichbarkeit andere Aspekte
langfristig eine große Rolle spielen
werden somit dafür sind wir als Bund
zuständig aber auch alleine zuständig
die vergütungs- und die Qualitäts
Erfordernisse für die Abrechnung sind
allein in der Zuständigkeit
des Bundes natürlich wollen wir diese
Reform mit den Ländern eng abstimmen
weil günstig wäre natürlich wenn die
Länder diese Aspekte welche Kliniken
haben die optimale Vorhaltung hier
welche Kliniken bringen welche Qualität
welche Klinik gehört in welche
Versorgungsstufe wenn das bei der
Planung berücksichtigt wurde da würden
wir uns sehr freuen aber da haben wir
keine Zuständigkeit und das Trennen wir
auch sehr eng daher sind wir mit den
Ländern im Einvernehmen Länder behalten
die Krankenhausplanung wir machen
Qualität und Vergütung was zehn Jahren
möglich ist war es niemand von uns ich
glaube dass also der Trends zu
ambulantisierung der im Ausland längst
also zugange ist dass der auch bei uns
beginnen wird schon allein durch die
Reformen die wir am Freitag beschlossen
haben die tagesstationäre Versorgung die
hybridiativ ist wenn man sich überlegt
wie viele Eingriffe wir noch stationär
machen die im Ausland links ambulant
gemacht werden Kniegelenks also Ersatz
wird mittlerweile in Amerika häufig
schon ambulant gemacht weil wir noch
einen Kreuzbandriss stationär versorgen
das sind natürlich riesige Unterschiede
also ganz ganz große Unterschiede und
die Qualität spricht er für die
ambulante Versorgung ich glaube dass
unsere Medizin sich da auch auf den Weg
machen wird und auf den Weg also sich
befinden aufholen wird wir werden das
was wir jetzt quasi verloren haben
werden wir aufholen wir werden auch mehr
ambulant machen wir werden auch stärker
die Qualität honorieren und wir werden
auch stärker mit digital Digitalisierung
arbeiten das auch ein sehr wichtiges
Konzept was noch folgt das nicht unser
Thema heute aber ich glaube die zwei
großen
modernisierungsdefizite in unserem
Gesundheitssystem sind auf der einen
Seite ein komplett in die Jahre
gekommenes System der Planung und der
Vergütung der Krankenhaus auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite ein
zehnjahresrückstand bei der
Digitalisierung im Krankenhaus und in
der ambulanten Medizin und beides sind
Schwerpunkte meiner Arbeit damit werde
ich mich die nächsten drei Jahre sehr
intensiv beschäftigen weil wir haben in
beiden Bereichen haben wir jahrelang
über die Probleme diskutiert es ist aber
kaum etwas passiert
ganz kurz weil sie die Zahl der Betten
gerade genannt haben die wir angeblich
in Deutschland haben sie wissen dass sie
ein großer Freund von Datenerhebung bin
in den Krankenhäusern das ist mitnichten
so dass wir noch diese Zahl von wirklich
mit personalbetreibbaren Betten in
Deutschland haben und das A und O für
eine vernünftige Planung in der Zukunft
ist dass wir eine sehr gute
Datengrundlage schaffen deswegen werden
auch in unserem Konzept alle
Krankenhäuser verpflichtet in Register
zu melden ja wir können nicht mehr so
weitermachen wie bisher wir müssen
wissen wie viel Betten am Netz sind und
es ist mittlerweile normal das ein
Drittel aller normalstationsbetten im
Krankenhaus nicht mehr Betreiber sind
weil wir einfach kein Personal haben das
heißt diese Zahl die immer durch die
mediengeistert stimmt überhaupt nicht
mehr mit dem Klinikalltag über einen und
ich glaube deswegen ist extrem wichtig
dass du diesen zweiten Schub
Digitalisierung aus der Pandemie jetzt
noch mal aufnehmen und dass wir in
Zukunft wirklich eine real time
Übertragung haben wie viele entdecken
kann ich betreiben mit intensivregister
sehen wir dass wir alleine in den
letzten zwei Jahren 25 Prozent der Heike
Intensivbetten in Deutschland verloren
haben weil wir einfach kein Personal
mehr haben um die zu betreiben und
deswegen ist das ein zweites ganz
wichtiges Standbein Digitalisierung des
Gesundheitswesens real time Monitoring
der Kapazitäten und natürlich alles
darüber hinaus damit wir auch endlich
elektronisch sehen was der Patient hat
oder was die Patientin hat
aber ich habe noch mal eine Einschätzung
Frage wenn man das verfolgt hat vor 20
Jahren die Einführung der diadies und
das habe ich getan kommt mir das so vor
also alle diese Argumente die sie jetzt
sagen wurden damals auch ausgesprochen
begründet waren bekannt es ist in der
Pflege so gelaufen dass die
Ökonomisierung die Oberhand hat in dem
Krankenhausversorgung auch und es gibt
auch noch andere Bereiche
meine Frage ist
sind das 20 verlorene Jahre oder war
dieser um dich notwendig
was heißt 20 verlorene Jahre wir haben
natürlich in dieser Zeit auch also sehr
vielen Menschen eine sehr gute
medizinische Versorgung in den
Krankenhäusern in zu kommen lassen aber
auf der anderen Seite ist es so durch
die 100% Einführung des dlg-systems zu
damaligen Zeit haben wir es der Medizin
nicht leichter gemacht ich kann das
selbst zum Beispiel aus der Perspektive
der Uniklinik sehr gut also beurteilen
wo er noch mehr an Institut an der Uni
Köln ist und die Uniklinik Köln ist auch
ein kalkulationshaus für die also
Verantwortlichen von daher Überblick ich
die Lage doch recht gut und das ist
einfach schade wenn eine Klinik sich
überlegen muss wie also die besonders
aufwendigen Patienten versorgt werden
können ohne dass man damit Defizite
machen und das funktioniert dann in der
Regel so in dem halt sehr viele Fälle
auch gemacht werden die man eigentlich
in einem Haus der Grund und der also
Regelversorgung versorgen könnte und das
sind dann wenn man so will Verdünner und
ein solches System dass ich mit
verdünnerfällen arbeiten muss um
besonders aufwendige Fälle zu bezahlen
ist kein gutes System somit es waren
keine verlorenen Jahre aber es waren
schwierige Jahre und richtig bekannt
also hart bekannt dass das System uns
schadet dass also es seit zehn Jahren
der Fall in der Tat eben kam da diese
Frage auch ob das
ecotic dieses Qualitäts ist also
Institut ob das jetzt überflüssig werden
das ist nicht so aber die alleinige
Beobachtung der Qualität macht sie noch
nicht besser und man macht sie nur
besser indem man also Bürokratie abbaut
digitalisiert und den Krankenhäusern
wirklich also auch Luft lässt
die medizinischen Aspekte in den
Vordergrund zu stellen und nicht im
Hamsterrad einfallen nach dem anderen
ablassen zu müssen
für unsere wissenschaftliche Arbeit in
der Regierungskommission stehen wir ja
vor der Herausforderung man kann ja
keine randomisierten Studien machen und
die Hälfte Krankenhäuser so finanzieren
die andere so ab sondern was ziehen wir
heran wir können den internationalen
Vergleich heranziehen und den
historischen Vergleich und da sind wir
eigentlich in einer ganz guten Situation
dass wir hier in Deutschland auf
mindestens jetzt drei verschiedene
Systeme die Krankenhäuser zu finanzieren
zurückblicken können und die wurden
jeweils sehr radikal zu 100 % umgesetzt
ganz früher hat mir das Selbstkosten
deckungsprinzip in Westdeutschland bzw
die Staatsmedizin in Ostdeutschland da
wurden einfach die Kosten hier entstehen
weitergereicht das hat dann dazu geführt
dass er in effizient und
verschwenderisch gearbeitet wurde dann
hatten wir das System mit den
liegepauschalen für
Behandlungstag gab es einfach eine feste
Summe das hat eben zu unvertretbar lange
Behandlungsdauern geführt wenn man am in
die hohen Kosten hatte dann hat man das
dadurch refinanziert dass meine
Patienten dann hinterher noch drei
Wochen zur Beobachtung da behalten hat
wo man kaum noch Ausgaben hatte und
jetzt hatten wir das dlg-system was
genau dieses auch durchaus positiv
beeinflusst hat diese überlangen
Behandlungsdauer im Krankenhaus sind ja
drastisch dramatisch weniger geworden
wir sehen aber eben die ganzen
skizzierten Probleme in dieses
fallpauschalsystems und daraus folgt
jetzt die Logik unseres unserer
Empfehlung dass man eben
solche Systeme kombiniert und nicht
radikal nur auf den Einen oder nur auf
den anderen Umsatz setzt das heißt wir
haben jetzt mit der ähm mit der vorhalte
Finanzierung eben eine Säule die
vorhandene Kosten finanziert behalten
aber eben ein Teil deshalb
pauschalsystems weil insofern die
Antwort auf Ihre Frage das war nicht
komplett verlorene Jahre es hat eben
durchaus auch dass erfüllt was man sich
erhofft hatte von der Einführung der
Fallpauschale des Systems
hat sich fast überschnitten mit dem was
gerade ausgeführt hatte mich hat das
doch auch gereizt wenn Sie Fragen haben
wir verlorene Jahre ich denke wir haben
keine verlorenen Jahre gehabt weil wir
sehr viel auch qualitativ in den
Krankenhäusern verändert haben wir haben
den medizinischen Fortschritt
[Musik]
seinen Raum gegeben wir haben
Innovationen eingeführt die auch mit
dazu geführt haben dass sich die
Verweilzeiten in
vielen Kliniken oder in bei vielen
Verhandlungen deutlich Behandlungen
deutlich verringert haben und das
ermutigt uns auch diesen Schritt
weiterzugehen was sicher
das System behindert hat ist diese
strikte Trennung der Sektoren die
ambulante Versorgung in niedergelassenen
Bereich und die stationäre versorg in
den Krankenhäusern da sind wir in
Deutschland wirklich hinter vielen
vielen anderen auch europäischen
Nachbarländern und da sehen wir die
Chance dass wir das auch über dieses
Grundkonzept was wir heute vorgestellt
haben in den nächsten Jahren deutlich
verbessern können dass wir das was die
Infrastruktur eines Krankenhauses
braucht an behandeln die Behandlung die
diese Infrastruktur braucht künftig aber
als Ambulanz Setting im Krankenhaus
durchführen können da unterscheiden wir
uns ganz wesentlich von unseren Nachbarn
und das ist auch ein Anspruch den wir
haben hier
auch im Sinne der Patienten zu handeln
denn ein Patient der nicht im
Krankenhaus zu übernachten muss hat
natürlich auch eine eine bessere
Situation auch schnell zu genießen als
wenn er ohne dass es medizinisch
notwendig ist das Krankenhaus
Bett in der Nacht belegen muss also das
ist ein Anachronismus in Deutschland den
wir sicher ganz schnell wenn wir auch
das eingeübt haben wie die Krankenhäuser
die Prozesse verändern ganz schnell
umsetzen werden
Stefan von ZEIT ONLINE ich vermute dass
ich meine Frage am Essen an Herrn
wenn Sie jetzt die Kliniken neu in
versorgungsselfällt einteilen und
Kriterien festlegen für die Gabe der
vorhaltebudgets besteht ja nicht die
Gefahr dass einige Kliniken da hinten
runterfallen vielleicht das auch nicht
überleben werden diesen Systemwechsel
weil sie ihre Kosten in diesem Budgets
nicht decken können das würde mich
interessieren wie weit da vielleicht
auch dann die wohnortnahe Versorgung
gefährdet werden könnte und zweiter
Punkt noch einen Lauterbach sie haben ja
jetzt so schwungvoll versprochen dass
keine Lobbygruppe Einfluss auf die
Umsetzung haben wird mich wenn
interessieren die wollen Sie dieses
Versprechen ein
insbesondere wenn es dann in ihrem Haus
an die Gesetzestexte geht und dann im
Parlament über das Gesetz debattiert und
abgestimmt wird
soll ich anfangen
wir denken das gerade die Level die
Chance sind die flächendeckende
Versorgung für die Bevölkerung
sicherzustellen weil man zum ersten Mal
definieren kann eben Level 1 muss ich
kleinräumig planen da muss eine kurze
Erreichbarkeit sein Level 1 n haben sich
schon gehört die die Notfallversorgung
kennen sicherstellen da sind kurze
Wegzeiten ja besonders erforderlich
Level 3
Maximalversorger
Transplantationsmedizin da kann man auch
eine Fahrzeit von 200 Kilometern er ein
Fahrradweg von 200 km oder so in Kauf
nehmen also das bedeutet das und bei
diesem Level 1 i besteht gerade die
Chance für kleine krankenhaushäuser
dabei zu bleiben Wohnort die Versorgung
sicherzustellen weil sie eben auch
ambulant arbeiten können weil sie nicht
zwingen 24 Stunden Ärzte vorhalten
müssen was wegen des Personalmangels
immer schwieriger wird weil sie
pflegerisch geleitet werden können und
weil sie komplett aus dem dialgie-system
rausgenommen sollen so dass sie auch gar
nicht diese Zwang zur Menge der Fälle
haben also wir sind da eigentlich denken
das ist eher besser wird
ja noch mal zurück zur wirtschaftlichen
Lage weil die ist wirklich sehr
angespannt wir gehen im Moment davon aus
dass jetzt schon bis zu 40 Prozent der
Kliniken in Deutschland
insolvenzgefährdet sein können und bis
zu 60 Prozent rote Zahlen schreiben
werden dieses Jahr alleine schon und das
ist eine ganz schön große Bürde die da
vor uns liegt und sie haben extrem
wichtigen Punkt adressiert und es wird
nicht ohne Wandel gehen ja und wenn ich
Geschäftsführer wäre eines Krankenhauses
dann habe ich jetzt mit diesem Modell
die Möglichkeit dass ich entweder sage
okay ich werde schlanker ich mache so
ein Level 1 i und reduziere natürlich
auch sehr viele Kosten die ich außenrum
habe um den Patienten ja und
konzentriere mich voll auf die
pflegerische Versorgung dann glaube ich
dass man mit Tagespauschalen solche
Häuser auch wirklich wirtschaftlich
führen kann auf der anderen Seite haben
die Kliniken jetzt aber auch das erste
Mal die Möglichkeit
Leistungsgruppen untereinander zu
tauschen im Moment ist es ja so sie
haben in Köln ist eine überversorgte
Region ja sie haben extrem viele
Krankenhäuser ganz viele dieser
Krankenhäuser haben gleiche
Fachabteilungen Innere Medizin
Kardiologie oder so durch unsere feine
Einteilung mit den 128 Leistungsgruppen
könnten die Geschäftsführer jetzt
hergehen einen runden Tisch machen in
Köln und sagen okay meine
Leistungsgruppe hier da habe ich
eigentlich gar nicht so viele Fälle du
hast ja eigentlich viel mehr und die
könnten jetzt wenn Sie es klug machen
hergehen und sagen okay du kriegst die
wenigen Fälle von mir noch ich erfülle
dann diese Leistungsgruppe gar nicht
mehr und auf der anderen Seite bekomme
ich von dir aber z.B Leistungsgruppe
Urologie ja weil ich davon viel mehr
mache und ich viel mehr Personal dafür
zur Verfügung habe das heißt wir kriegen
eine deutliche Zentrierung der
Leistungen damit können sie deutlich
effizienter arbeiten und das sehe ich
als die eigentlich große Chance für die
Krankenhäuser an und dadurch dass wir
das erste Mal auch einführen was ist
eigentlich ein Krankenhaus ja wir haben
ja klare strukturvoraussetzungen jetzt
für die Level 123 kann man sich als
Geschäftsführer auch überlegen entweder
ich grade ab bedeutet ich tue mich mit
zwei anderen Kliniken zusammen und baue
vielleicht neu ein Thema das wir
sicherlich noch besprechen müssen oder
ich grade halt down und werde schlanker
damit ich am Ende wieder wirtschaftlich
arbeiten kann das heißt das System
bietet für die Krankenhauslandschaft in
Deutschland unglaubliche Möglichkeiten
und was wir in diesem Papier auch
empfohlen haben ist noch mal die
Neuauflage des Strukturfonds ja weil wir
müssen darüber reden dass wir Neubauten
haben wir müssen hin zum Green Hospital
das ist mir eine Herzensangelegenheit
wir haben größte Schwierigkeiten wir
haben extrem viel alte Bausubstanz in
Deutschland wir haben in den hochsommern
Patienten die vor Fenster liegen wo es
draußen schon fast 40 Grad ist und drin
schon fast 50 Grad ohne Klimaanlage da
müssen wir dann an diesen Punkt und
deswegen haben wir auch noch mal
empfohlen dass wir den Strukturfonds
auflegen und ich würde ihnen und das
meine persönliche Meinung auch ganz klar
an green Hospital koppeln Herr Minister
ja nur ganz kurz also Lobbygruppen
werden gehört aber beeinflussen die
Gesetze bei uns nicht die Verfahren sind
transparent wir arbeiten mit den
Wissenschaftlern zusammen mit den
Fraktionen und den Ländern und das hat
bei der energiehilfe jetzt gut geklappt
da ist ja auch der letzten Woche unser
Entwurf im gaspreisbremsen Gesetzt
eingebracht worden oder hier bei den
kinderheilkundegesetzen die viel
gesetzlich erwähnt hatte Krankenhaus
entlastungsgesetz aber auch in der
Pandemie Politik das heißt Lobbygruppen
werden gehört aber man Eindruck ist
einfach das in der Vergangenheit einfach
zu viel Einfluss hatten das ist mein
Eindruck und den möchte ich einfach
begegnen
Andreas Hoffmann vom Stern ich habe muss
noch mal zum Geld was fragen und zwar
sie müssen ja diese Reform mit den
Ländern durchfechten und Sie müssen sie
mit den gesundheitsverbänden
zu politischen einmal eins gehört
eigentlich immer das im Gesundheitswesen
nur dann was funktioniert wenn man Geld
ausgibt und wo sie kein Geld ausgeben
anders als die Ideen zum Beispiel wollen
sie eigentlich das äh diese würden da
überwinden nur mit reinen Appellen oder
haben sie noch irgendeinen Trick auf
Lager in die integrierte Versorgung
kommt ja auch deswegen nicht zustande
weil die Ärzte nicht auf Geld verzichten
wollen die Krankenkassen nicht mehr
bezahlen wollen die Kliniken ebenfalls
Geld verdienen wollen und der zweite
Punkt der mich noch ist
wo sind eigentlich die Interessen der
kleinen Kliniken in diesen in dieser
Reformkommission vertreten weil die
Vertreter vertreten in der Regel fast
alle nur große Kliniken und unsere
kleine Klinik ist ja oft so dass die auf
dem Land dann verschwinden und nichts
mehr übrig
hat zunächst einmal die Frage ist ja
muss man Geld in die Hand nehmen um die
Zustimmung der Länder oder der Verbände
zu erreichen fangen wir mit den
Verbänden an wir machen ja die Gesetze
und nicht die Verbände das heißt wir
brauchen de facto keine Zustimmung der
Verbände und die Länder sehen die
Notwendigkeit der Reform ja auch wir
haben gestern mit den Ländern Oktober
gesprochen die Länder versuchen ja auch
sogar eigene Reformen die es auf den Weg
zu bringen Niedersachsen und NRW sind
schon erwähnt worden somit begrüßen die
Länder dass wir hier etwas machen und
wissen das auch und wir ziehen hier am
gleichen Strand und da ist dieses Bild
also ein Bild was auch nicht hilft das
ist früher vielleicht mal so gewesen
dass man also Verbände oder
Kassen oder wen auch immer
Hilfe bitten muss und wenn man gesetzt
machen will dann Geld in die Hand nehmen
muss so ist in der Vergangenheit oft
gearbeitet worden das ist aber hier
weder notwendig noch vorgesehen das
zweite Punkt ist also die also und über
die Hybrid sind ein gutes Beispiel
darüber wird auch seit zehn Jahren
gesprochen wir haben das jetzt am
Freitag eingeführt qualgesetz und als
auch kein Geld geflossen ich wir kämen
nicht auf die Idee jetzt beispielsweise
zu überlegen wer muss jetzt wie viel
bekommen damit wir die hybrides
einführen dürfen oder was auch immer in
der Vergangenheit hat man sich oft
Widerstände erspart indem man Geld in
die Hand genommen hat und hat dann
nachher doch kein gutes Gesetz gehabt so
können wir nicht mehr arbeiten das will
doch nicht nach vorne bringen die
Tatsache dass die kleinen Häuser hier
berücksichtigt worden sind hat er sehr
eloquent der Karriere schon gesagt die
kleinen Häuser werden hier endlich aus
diesem Hamsterrad herausgenommen und
müssen nicht mehr die komplizierten
Eingriffe erbringen die Sie derzeit
machen müssen um genug Budget zu
bekommen sondern die vorharte Pauschale
reicht aus und tatsächlich diese
Versorgung die Verordnung notwendig ist
erbringen zu können wenn ihr
ich habe jetzt erst einmal über das
Ergebnis gesprochen und käme jetzt dazu
also kann ein Ergebnis zugunsten der
kleinen Kliniken auch zustande kommen
wenn kein Vertreter kleiner Kliniken in
der Kommission war das ist durchaus
möglich war die Kommission ist ja
besetzt worden durch Wissenschaftler und
nicht durch also Interessensvertreter
das heißt sie sind hier noch in der
alten denk Logik Herr Hoffmann dass sie
denken also da muss aus jeder
Betroffenen Klinikgruppe und vielleicht
auch aus dem Krankenkassen jemand dabei
sitzen damit ein Pferd das Ergebnis zu
sein stand da kommt das ist ja eine
Wissenschaftler Kommission gewesen die
sich mit dem krankenhaussystem in der
Grenze beschäftigt groß wie klein
mal ganz kurz was zur
volkswirtschaftlichen Bedeutung und zu
diesem Vergleich von Dänemark sagen wir
haben es in Deutschland ja geschafft
dass wir mittlerweile 13,1 Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes für das
Gesundheitswesens ausgeben und wir sind
eine der wenigen OECD-Staaten und zwar
genau im Gegensatz zu Dänemark die ist
in den letzten zehn Jahren geschafft
haben das auch noch substanziell zu
steigern ja das heißt wir haben schon
sehr viel Geld im System und wir können
nicht einfach immer mehr immer mehr da
reinmuttern das musste gewisse Grenze
geben wir müssen aber das viele Geld das
wir haben deutlich effizienter einsetzen
und das ist glaube ich unsere große
Stellschraube und der zweite Punkt zu
Dänemark noch auch da kann Dänemark
wieder ein Vorbild sein wie auch an
anderen Stellen dänemark hat erkannt
dass eine sehr starke Zentralisierung
auf wenige Krankenhäuser eben genau
nicht funktioniert weil es
ältere chronisch kranke Patienten gibt
die in der Fläche versorgt werden müssen
und deswegen geht Dänemark den Schritt
zurück und baut jetzt genau wieder diese
Zentren wie wir sie uns vorstellen die
Level 1 Kliniken in Deutschland damit
man die älterwerdende chronisch Kranke
Bevölkerung versorgen kann die vereinten
pflegerische Zuwendung braucht und als
Internist habe ich vielleicht auch mal
sagen sie können 80% der Erkrankung
dafür brauchen sie nicht viel Diagnostik
und nicht viel Therapie das können sie
sehr gut vor Ort machen und für die 20
Prozent reicht die Verlegung in ein
Zentrum und ich glaube deswegen ist der
Weg in Dänemark und auch der bei uns mit
diesen Level 1 Kliniken wichtig und
richtig richtig
schon gesagt das ist nicht die Idee dass
jeder in der Kommission seine Interessen
vertritt wir haben auch keinen Vertreter
der Urologie und keine Vertreterin der
Orthopädie und ich kann nur aus der
intensiven Arbeit der
Regierungskommission sagen dass es auch
wirklich so funktioniert also wir
arbeiten da am Gesamtkonzept und haben
diese gesamte System im Blick und
niemand vertritt er sein Interesse ganz
abgesehen davon dass ich selbst aus
einem bestenfalls mittelgrößen
Krankenhaus gekommen das auch nicht so
einem Klinik Konzern gehört
alleinstehend ist und weil so viel nach
den Verbänden gefragt wurde wollte ich
nur zur Arbeitsweise der
Regierungskommission ergänzen dass wir
uns da eine Verfahrensordnung gegeben
haben und in strukturierten Anhörungen
die Verbände einbinden für diese Reform
die Sie heute hier präsentiert bekommen
sind die sind sie strukturiert angehört
worden die Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft der
GKV-Spitzenverband der deutsche
pflegerad der Marburger Bund und da
kommen auch wichtige und gute Ideen die
wir durchaus aufgreifen wenn sie uns
sinnvoll erscheinen also da gibt es
jetzt nicht eine abschottungs-
die Kontraste sie haben jetzt sehr viele
langfristige mittelfristige Maßnahmen
vorgestellt
medizinische Versorgung ist aber auch
aktuell in der Krise in Deutschland der
Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung der sie ja
ins Amt gebracht hat der Lauterbach
schwindet und gleichzeitig sind viele
Ärzte auch unzufrieden führende
Mediziner sprechen von Inkompetenz was
macht das mit Ihnen
ja vielen Dank zunächst über den
Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung kann ich
mich nicht beklagen also ausweislich der
Umfragen die es dazu gibt kann also
nicht davon ausgegangen werden dass ich
wenig Rückhalt der nächste ganz also im
Gegenteil und für mich ist in erster
Linie wichtig dass ich eine gute Arbeit
mache dass wir beispielsweise mit nicht
zu vielen Sterbefälle durch die Pandemie
kommen nicht achte sehr darauf dass
ältere Menschen gut geschützt bleiben
obwohl viele die Pandemie für beendet
erklärt haben wollen ich habe gestern
den Ländern beispielsweise noch einmal
erklärt dass wenn nicht auf die
maskenpflicht im öffentlichen Personen
Nahverkehr verzichten können oder dass
wir also isolationspflicht nicht
bedenken aufzuheben die Dinge müssen
stimmen das muss einfach also
funktionieren und dann richtig meine
Arbeit aus auch also an beispielsweise
an einer solchen Kommission ich glaube
dass die Gesetze gut vorbereitet sind
und daher also bin ich was dies angeht
mit mir selbst also im Reinen
ich will allerdings darauf hinweisen wir
arbeiten wirklich sehr eng also mit
Wissenschaftlern auf allen Ebenen
zusammen Expertenrat diese Kommission
andere Kommission das heißt die
Rückversicherung dass das was wir tun
auch gut ist und funktioniert ist mir
sehr wichtig und da ist der Dialog mit
Wissenschaftlern eben bedeutsam aber
auch mit den Verbänden und den Ländern
das wird regelmäßig durchgeführt hat
gestern noch stattgefunden
vielen Dank sie hatten die
ausbleibenden Zahlungen der Länder für
die Investitionskosten der Krankenhäuser
schon angesprochen ich frage mich wie
viel kann diese Reform
entlasten die Krankenhäuser wenn sie
weiterhin möglicherweise
aus dem Betrieb für Investitionen
aufbringen müssen gerne an einen der
Experten
ich möchte Ihnen gerne eine Antwort
darauf geben es ist in der vergangenen
Jahren genauso gewesen wie Sie es
beschreiben dass die Krankenhäuser aus
den
Betriebskosten oder aus den
betriebserträgen über die DRGs ein Teil
der
Investitionsaufwendungen geschultert
haben einfach um
sowohl was die Gebäude als auch was das
medizintechnische Gerät anbelangt
einigermaßen in dem Standard der Zeit zu
bleiben die Forderung nach auskömmlicher
Investitionsfinanzierung durch die
Länder und das ist nun mal Länder
Aufgabe ist ein Thema dass wir auch in
der Kommission schon erörtert haben aber
was jetzt nicht eingeflossen ist in
dieses Papier des Grundkonzept der
Finanzierung der Betriebsausgaben wir
haben uns das vorgenommen als eine der
nächsten wesentlichen Themen und da wird
es sicher einen intensiven Austausch
auch mit den Ländern darüber geben wie
weit die Länder auch diese Vorstellungen
teilen um mal so eine Größenordnung zu
nennen
die
Investitionskosten im Verhältnis zu den
Betriebsausgaben sollten
mindestens bei 7 bis 8 Prozent liegen
ich schaue immer sehr fasziniert in die
Schweiz die Schweiz hat ja vier fünf
Jahre nach uns die diadies eingeführt
aber mit einem Pragmatismus den ich
einfach nur gut finde die haben 10%
drauf geschlagen auf die dlgs für die
Investitionsausgaben und das ist was was
bei uns sicher so jetzt in dem stand in
dem wir sind nicht mehr möglich ist
gerade auch wegen der Abkehr von der
reinen
die Vergütung in ein zwei Säulensystem
aber das entbindet uns nicht davon dass
wir die
Investitionsausgaben deutlich steigern
müssen denn das ist mit ein Problem auch
für die Unzufriedenheit des Personals
wenn sie in abgewirtschaften gebeuten
arbeiten müssen wenn Sie sehen dass es
für den Patienten einfach keine adäquate
Unterkunft gibt weil es zum Teil immer
noch drei und Vierbettzimmer gibt weil
es keine ausreichende
Klimatisierung gibt und weil das was im
Moment auch jeder ja persönlich gerne
umsetzen möchte die man Nachhaltigkeit
wenn Sie das in den Krankenhäusern gar
nicht realisieren können zum Teil sind
die Krankenhäuser noch nicht mal mehr in
der Lage
überall LED Lampen
einzubauen weil auch dafür das Geld
fehlt also das ist eine missliche
Situation und es ist nicht die
Zuständigkeit des Bundes es ist die
Zuständigkeit der Länder aber in einem
guten
Austausch mit den Ländern ist
ist es notwendig dass man diese
Erkenntnisse auch bei den Ländern dann
verinnerlicht und hoffentlich auch trotz
der finanziellen Misere auch hier
Lösungen findet also das ist ein Thema
das können wir nicht
zur Seite schieben sondern das muss
genauso angepackt werden wie wir jetzt
uns über die grundlegende Finanzierung
der Betriebskosten Gedanken gemacht
haben
ist ja auch ein Widerspruch also auf der
einen Seite sagen sie insgesamt es gibt
sehr sehr viel Geld in diesem System
dann fehlt es auf der anderen Seite um
eine LED-Lampe auszutauschen ich will
noch mal auf die Profiteure dieses
Systems kommen es gibt ja Helios
Vivantes gibt große Konzerne die sehr
sehr große Gewinne gemacht haben jetzt
sagen Sie das wird in Zukunft nicht mehr
so leicht sein Gewinne zu machen wenn
aber die Reaktion ist dass sie dann
sagen okay dann ist es für uns auch kein
lukratives Geschäft mehr haben sie
dieses diese Variante mal durchgespielt
ja das ist in der Tat so wenn der ein
oder andere also Investor dann die also
Konsequenz zieht wer also investieren
nicht in zusätzliche Häuser wir kaufen
nicht dann könnte das eine Folge sein
aber das kann ja keine Überlegung für
unsere Politik sein das muss wirklich so
sein dass im Vordergrund steht
wie können wir sicherstellen dass nicht
so weitergeht wie jetzt billige Medizin
und in die Masse billig und Masse ist
das Gebot der Stunde das muss weg wir
brauchen also eine Versorgung oder
Qualität im Vordergrund steht daher die
Vorhaltekosten die unterschiedlichen
Niveaus so dass die Fälle den richtigen
Niveaus zugeordnet werden und ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass es genug
Anbieter im deutschen System gibt die
dem also gerecht werden können das ist
ja nicht so dass wir von einer Situation
starten wo wir sagen müssen wir haben
einen solchen krankenhausmangel dass man
bei jeder Reform ist darauf achten muss
das nicht dann Krankenhaus verloren geht
wir haben ja an vielen Bereichen eher
also mehr Krankenhäuser als medizinisch
unbedingt notwendig wären somit sind die
Voraussetzungen für die Reform
eigentlich gut
eben wurde von den Kollegen schon gesagt
hier auf dem Podium wir haben eigentlich
sehr viel Geld im System das ist eine
gute Voraussetzung und die zweite gute
Voraussetzung ist wir haben eigentlich
auch ein breites Angebot wir müssen es
eben nur besser organisieren
ich habe noch einige wenige Fragen noch
hat der Minister nicht gesagt dass er
gleich aufstehen muss vielleicht kriegen
wir die durch bei kurzen Fragen kurzen
Antworten und der Junge ist der nächste
ich verzichte danke schön dann machen
wir weiter bei den Kollegen
Investitionsmitteln kann denn ihre
Reform funktionieren wenn die Länder
weiterhin zu wenig Investitionskosten
übermittelt überweisen wenn das System
ist ja weiterhin unter finanziert und
ein großes Problem ist ja auch der
Fachkräftemangel im System wird der
Fachkräftemangel durch ihre Reform
implizit irgendwie auch mit eingegangen
also zunächst die Reform ist notwendig
genauso wie die Steigerung der
investitionskostenhilfe durch die
Ländern notwendig ist und wir verhandeln
ja mit den Ländern aber es ist nicht so
dass diese Reform nicht funktionieren
würde wenn sich bei den
Investitionskosten nichts verändern
würde die
investitionskostenreform ist keine
notwendige Bedingung für das also
Gelingen dieser Reform ich sage es mal
so die wir haben genug Geldsystem wir
brauchen eine bessere Finanzierung der
Investitionskosten aber das System ist
insgesamt jetzt nicht also darauf
angewiesen dass zusätzliches Geld ist
erstmal beschafft werden muss um die
Form zu ermöglichen denken Sie an die
Übergangsphase von fünf Jahren die z.B
der nediska beschrieben hat und der
zweite Punkt ist wir verlieren ja jedes
Jahr Fachkräfte die das Krankenhaus
verlassen weil diese Art zu arbeiten
Ihnen nicht mehr gefällt das geht für
viele Pflegekräfte das geht für viele
Ärzte für Ärztinnen
im Krankenhaus wird also als Arbeitgeber
zunehmend uninteressant weil eben diese
ökonomischen Aspekte eine große Rolle
spielen also keiner will in einem
verfallenden Krankenhaus
Medizin machen die medizinisch
vielleicht nicht unbedingt optimal ist
die aber die Gewinne des Betreibers
maximiert das will einfach niemand das
wollen auch junge Leute nicht mehr von
daher verlieren wir das hat
unnötigerweise Fachkräfte
aus der Klinik heraus und das muss dem
begegnen wir durch die Reform ganz
entschieden
niemand hat die Illusion des der
Fachkräftemangel ausschließlich durch
Ausbildung und Zuwanderung zu bewältigen
ist und deswegen setzt die
Reformvorschläge der
Regierungskommission eben auch vor allem
daran an unnötige Leistungen und
unnötigen Aufwand zu reduzieren damit
mit dem vorhandenen Personal vor allem
das gemacht werden kann was wirklich
nötig ist also wenn wir den Anreiz für
die Menge reduzieren dann reduziert das
natürlich auch Arbeitsstunden wenn wir
dem Level 1i ambulante Möglichkeiten
schaffen dann reduziert das den 24
Stunden Aufwand und am Freitag ist ja
auch auf der Basis von Vorschlägen der
Regierungskommission unter anderem die
tagesbehandlung als grundsätzliche
Möglichkeit für die Krankenhäuser
geschaffen worden auch das adressiert
den Personalmangel damit eben
Nachtschichten zum Beispiel bei guter
kluger auch um Organisation der
Krankenhäuser eingespart werden können
werden haben eigentlich einen relativen
Personalmangel kein absoluten jedenfalls
wenn wir uns mit unseren europäischen
Nachbarn vergleichen pro Bevölkerung und
dieses Personal müssen wir klüger
einsetzen und so einsetzen dass es nicht
davon läuft weil die Bedingungen
unerträglich sind
Nummer ein Punkt zu Investitionskosten
ganz kurz ich hänge sehr an diesem
Strukturfonds ja und am besten gekoppelt
an ökologischen nachhaltige Bauweise ja
damit wir nicht wieder die gleichen
Fehler machen der letzten 20 30 Jahre
und dieser Strukturform ist eine riesen
Chance dass wir den Kliniken auch
abseits der regulären Investitionskosten
eine Möglichkeit eröffnen würden dass
sie ihre bauliche Substanz verbessern
das ist ein Appell an Bund und Länder
diesen Struktur von normal aufzulegen
das ist uns wichtig deswegen haben wir
es auch so geschrieben und jetzt eigen
ist ja auch schon mal gesagt der heutige
Tag muss ein Stück weit auch eine Zensur
darstellen wir werden das nur schaffen
wenn Bund und Länder zusammenarbeiten
und dazu gehört natürlich auch
dass die Kliniken mehr als die 3,4
Prozent Investitionskosten die wir im
Moment haben und das auch von der Seite
das ganze flankiert und unterstützt wird
bitteschön freier Journalist ich sehe im
neuen Vergütungssystem eine sehr starke
inputorientierung ist es denn möglich in
diesem System auch abzubilden
medizinische outkamps auch mit einer
Ergebnisorientierung
ja vielen Dank also das Konzept sieht
auf der Strecke das wird ja über fünf
Jahre so als eingeführt werden auch
Aspekte vor wo Qualität eine Rolle
spielt wo also eine Rolle spielt wie gut
sind die Kliniken erreichbar wie ist die
demografische Abdeckung die hier also
geschultert werden muss somit also
werden auch Qualitätsaspekte und
Mengen Aspekte wie aber auch also
demografische Aspekte eine Rolle spielen
bei der Umsetzung ich dachte eher ein
medizinische outkamps das habe ich ja
gesagt Qualität wurde hier an den Ort
kam es auch gemessen werden können das
System einmal eingeführt es könnte man
sich durchaus vorstellen dass es
irgendwann beispielsweise dann auch eine
Momente gibt wo besonders gute Qualität
noch einen Zuschlag bekommt aber wir
müssen jetzt erst einmal in eine
Situation kommen das Qualität überhaupt
eine Rolle spielt bei der Bezahlung und
wo nicht der anrats der ist das also die
Minderqualität mit geringem Aufwand den
höchsten Gewinn abwirft
der Punkt Ergebnis Qualität den haben
wir sehr lange diskutiert das ist ein
extrem schwieriger weil sie müssen ihn
trennscharf hinbekommen wenn sie solche
vergütungskonzepte machen
er ist ja schon implementiert zum
Beispiel in den Krebszentren wir sehen
ja sehr eindeutig dass die
Ergebnisqualität deutlich besser ist in
den Krebszentren ich nehme jetzt mal
meinen Fachbereich den Lungenkrebs es
funktioniert einfach deutlich besser das
out kann es deutlich besser den
lungenkrebszentren und deswegen haben
wir da natürlich Ergebnis Qualität auch
ein Stück weit implementiert die
Regierungskommission wird hier mit
diesem Punkt noch mal getrennt befassen
weil er so schwierig ist in seiner
Trennschärfe
Jens Maul von bibliomed Verlage ich aber
auch noch mal eine Frage zu den Ländern
ist lange es schon teilweise an
angenommen die Länder machen nicht mit
was er nicht ganz auszuschließen ist ist
diese Reform dann noch zu 100% umsetzbar
oder viele dann was weg also wofür
konkret brauchen Sie die Länder in
dieser Reform
wie ich nehme hier nicht an was alles
schief laufen kann sondern ich arbeite
am Gelingen und daher also spekuliere
ich jetzt hier nicht darüber also ich
glaube dass die Länder hier mitmachen
werden die Gespräche die wir mit den
Ländern geführt haben auch bei den
anderen Formen die wir bisher gemacht
haben waren so da kamen dann wertvolle
Einwände neue Vorschläge aber zum
Schluss haben wir es dann doch gemacht
also ist am Vater geschlossen worden ist
ähnlich wird das hier auch sein wir
gehen nach vorne und wir finden die
Länder fair ein und damit haben wir
gestern schon was diesen Reformen Anteil
angeht begonnen aber die Länder wissen
dass wir hier einen miteinander suchen
und nicht erinnern Wettbewerb sind und
insbesondere Parteipolitik und ähnliche
Dinge dürfen keine Rolle spielen
ich möchte Herr Karan janides und Herrn
Lauterbach um die Aufklärung eines
Widerspruchs bitten innerhalb von
wenigen Zeilen Abstand wird jetzt
zitiert der Gesundheitsminister wir
müssen das fellpauschalen System
überwinden und die Kommission deshalb
pauschalen System muss weiterentwickelt
werden überwinden ist doch nach der
allgemeinen Begrifflichkeit etwas sehr
anderes als weiterentwickeln also was
gilt
dazu kann ich etwas eine
Betrachtungsweise für mich ist es eine
Überwindung und zwar dahingehend weil
also in dem Fall pauschalen System
derzeit die gesamt also budgetsumme wie
auch der Gewinn wie auch die Anreize wen
soll ich Behandeln von der also Vater
Schale abhängen also alle drei Fragen
mache ich gewinnen ja oder nein wie
behandle ich und also
wie plane ich die Eingriffe in allen
drei Dimensionen
dominiert derzeit also die Frage was
bringt mir der Fall wie viel verdiene
ich mit einem solchen Fall bin ein
Beispiel wenn jetzt also die Überlegung
die ist sollte ein Krankenhaus noch eine
weitere also lungenkrebsoperation machen
sondern solchen Patienten jetzt noch
aufnehmen dann spielt eben auch eine
Rolle wenn das ein planbarer Eingriff
ist auch andersrum gemacht werden könnte
kann ich den also Fall mit Gewinn machen
oder kostet mich der Fall Geld
habe ich meinen Budget schon ausgereizt
oder komme ich mit diesem Fall in den
Meer Erlös Ausgleich und wie mache ich
das also wie viel setze ich ein um den
Fall zu erbringen so dass sie mir keine
Verluste macht der Fall wird mit
dominiert durch die Art und Weise wer
bezahlt wird
und das überwinden wir das ist der dass
sie Überwindung sich dieser Dinge war
das spielt demnächst keine Rolle die
Vorhaltekosten für einen solchen Fall
habe ich sowieso ob ich in mache oder
nicht Gewinne werde ich auch nicht
machen weil er bringt mir dann relativ
gesprochen an zusätzlichem Geld nicht
mehr als was er mich kostet somit die
Gewinne Dimension ist weg und also ob
ich ihn mache oder nicht hängt davon ab
ob ich überhaupt diesen Leistungskomplex
zugewiesen habe ja oder nein somit wurde
in allen drei Dimensionen wo ich jetzt
bisher denke was bringt mir der Fall
fahrbarschale würde das keine Rolle mehr
spielen daher betrachte ich diese Reform
aus der praktischen Sicht aus als andere
Form wo man sagen kann das überwindet
das war wahrscheinlich ein System
aus meiner Sicht dazu wir sollten uns
nicht zu sehr in einzelnen Wörtern
aufhängen aber Weiterentwicklung ist ein
zu schwaches Wort für das was wir hier
vorlegen das ist schon eine echte
grundreform und ich glaube je mehr sie
in der Klinik drinstecken desto mehr
merkt man auch so fort wenn jetzt
plötzlich einzelne Kliniken Leistung
nicht mehr erbringen dürfen dafür andere
Kliniken das zentriert machen wenn man
nicht mehr diesen sehr starken
ökonomischen Druck hat dass man im
Sommer auch eine Vollbelegung braucht
damit man überhaupt noch auskömmlich ist
dann hat das vielleicht jetzt nicht
gerade ein revolutions Charakter aber
ein extremen Einfluss auf den Klinik
Alltag das würde ich schon sagen und was
wir überwinden ist glaube ich wirklich
die über Ökonomisierung des
Gesundheitswesen ja Ökonomie ist nichts
Schlechtes darauf gründet unsere
Gesellschaft deswegen müssen wir einen
gewissen Anteil erhalten davon aber das
was wir extrem übertrieben haben auch im
OECD Vergleich extrem übertrieben haben
die kein anderes Land das fahren wir
jetzt endlich und auch deutlich zurück
Lauterbach wie sicher sind Sie
eigentlich dass sie in ihrer Koalition
diese überwindungsrevolution tatsächlich
durchsetzen können es gibt da ja
relevante Player die es geradezu als
politische Vorsorgemaßnahme zu
betrachten scheinen den
Gesundheitsminister zu entsorgen
möglichst umgehend
also wie gesagt ich spekuliere nicht
über Erfolge sondern ich versuche sie zu
ermöglichen und es wird auch gelingen
ich habe jetzt noch drei Fragen einen
noch zum Thema und zwei offensichtlich
abverwandte die Kolleginnen zuerst mit
ihrer fragen Sie verzichten dann haben
wir noch zwei Fragen die Kollegen die
wir zurückgestellt haben dafür zuerst
danke schön Pfeffer RTL NTV Herr
Lauterbach zwei Fragen können Sie einmal
noch mal gesondert auf die
Kinderkliniken auf die aktuelle Lage
eingehen wieder dramatisch ist das und
das muss da jetzt geschehen und die
zweite Frage sie haben eben noch gesagt
die maskenpflicht in den ÖPNV ist ihm
wichtig Bayern hat jetzt gesagt Sie
wollen das Abschaffen zum 10 Dezember
was sagen sie dazu
ja die Lage in den Kinderkliniken ist
dramatisch und zeigt wie wichtig diese
Reformen sind an denen wir ja seit Mai
arbeiten und wo der erste Schritt
bereits also gegangen wurde
am Freitag als wir die
endbudgetierung der Kinderkliniken in
dem Korridor 80 bis 100% der Fälle für
das nächste Jahr beschlossen haben und
auch eine Zusatzfinanzierung der
Kinderkliniken um von 300 Millionen Euro
die RS Virus also Epidemie die haben wir
nicht nur in Deutschland die haben in
vielen europäischen Ländern auch in den
Vereinigten Staaten und wir müssen halt
alles tun um den Kindern hier zu helfen
ich habe daher sehr schnell reagiert und
habe die Kliniken aufgefordert
Pflegepersonal und auch ärztliches
Personal zu verlegen in die
Kinderkliniken wo immer das möglich ist
das hatte ich abgestimmt mit Leitern von
Kinderkliniken beispielsweise mit
Professor dötz aus der Uniklinik in Köln
oder Professor Abo Daten hier im Josef
Krankenhaus in Berlin aber auch anderen
Kliniken es ist richtig dass nicht jede
hochspezialisierte Versorgung eines
Kindes durch eine Fachkraft gebracht
erbracht werden kann die nicht in der
Kinderklinik ausgebildet wurde das ist
nicht möglich auf der anderen Seite gibt
es aber trotzdem die Möglichkeit der
Entlastung weil es auch
kinderklinikfälle gibt die leichter zu
versorgen sind wo Fachkräfte aus anderen
Abteilungen sehr wohl das übernehmen
können denken sie an zu
mandelentfernungen denken Sie an den
Winter am Operationen denken Sie an
keine Unfälle und so weiter und so fort
das heißt wenn das Personal aus anderen
Bereichen herangezogen wird und versorgt
die leichteren Fälle in der Kinderklinik
so dass das Fachpersonal dann
freigesetzt wird und kann sich den
besonders schwer erkranken Kindern mit
dieser also sind sozialen
Lungenentzündungen zu widmen dann ist
das eine massive Entlastung dafür haben
wir auch den rechtlichen Rahmen sofort
geschaffen die personaluntergrenzen
werden jetzt nicht mehr sanktioniert so
dass die Kliniken das per Pflegepersonal
aber auch das ärztliche Personal
verlegen können und von dem was ich aus
den Kliniken höre wird das auch gemacht
trotzdem dass wir in Zukunft nicht mehr
in solche Engpässe kommen ist einer der
Gründe weshalb wir heute hier sitzen das
ist einer der Gründe und ich hatte mir
die Entlastung der Kinderkliniken schon
vorgenommen bevor ich überhaupt wusste
ob wir die Wahl gewinnen geschweige denn
ob ich Minister werde weil ich habe also
seit Jahren schon gesehen dass die
Kinderkliniken als einen Bereich wo
keine Gewinne möglich sind besonders
abgebaut worden sind besonders abgebaut
und es geht in Köln Klinikum Amsterdamer
Straße Siegburger kinderklinikum das
geht für das Sand Josef für viele
Kliniken gilt das und ein System was
ausgerechnet Gewinne macht in dem bei
Kindern gespart wird ist ein krankes
System ein krankes System daher war das
das erste was ich mache wollte im Rahmen
der krankenhausreform das haben wir auch
gemacht da habe ich damals also die
Kommission gebeten Vorschläge zu machen
die haben wir eins zu eins umgesetzt und
schließlich was bayern macht ja ich bin
einfach davon nicht überzeugt wir haben
gestern darüber breit diskutiert die
sind einige Länder hat die bei den
Masken ÖPNV also und auch also bei der
isolationspflicht sehr früh sich
Verlockungen entschieden haben schon vor
Wochen ich habe mit Kollegen Wähler noch
einmal klar gemacht in der jetzigen
Situation wir haben eine noch
ansteckendere Variante zu erwarten Beko
1.1 bei dieser Variante wirken alle uns
bekannten Antikörper Medikamente nicht
wir können also bei schweren Verlauf in
der Klinik mit keinem Antikörper
Medikament überhaupt noch behandeln wir
haben andere wären beispielsweise RS
Virus wir haben eine sehr fröhende
schwere Grippe werde die begonnen hat es
gab fernwähler und für mich keine Gründe
jetzt zu sagen wir können lockern wir
können auf auf Isolation verpflichtet
verzichten somit also haben wir glaube
ich die meisten Länder dort überzeugen
können dass das in Baden-Württemberg und
also in Bayern in Hessen und auch in
Schleswig-Holstein nicht geschehen ist
das war vorher klar weil diese
Entscheidung waren ja vorher schon
getroffen worden ich finde es schade das
sind alles unionsgeführte Länder und ich
habe den Eindruck dass hier
Parteipolitik auch eine Rolle spielt und
das sollte einfach nicht sein wir
sollten einfach versuchen in diesem
Winter noch einmal zusammenstehen
zusammenzustehen wie wir das damals
gemacht haben
parteiübergreifend da haben wir also wir
sind eigentlich ganz gut durch die
Pandemie kommen erst im zweiten Jahr auf
deshalb weil Parteipolitik von der AFD
mal abgesehen keine Rolle gespielt hat
die Parteien haben zusammengestanden und
das muss auch für diesen Winter muss das
noch mal gelingen das ist mir sehr
wichtig daher haben wir da gestern
appelliert der Wähler und ich aber ich
glaube diese vier Ebenen erwähnten
Länder die hatten ja ihre Entscheidung
schon vorher getroffen und waren daher
nicht mehr durch Argumente erreichbar
ja und vielleicht auch noch mal zu dem
ersten jetzt mal ganz ehrlich mich
nerven die auch ja wenn sie stundenlang
in der Bahn sitzen und von Köln nach
Berlin fahren aber wenn wir auf der
anderen Seite sehen dass die
Kinderkliniken total voll sind mit der
ASV und Influenza kommt jetzt auch noch
dazu dann ist es ein Stück weit
vielleicht auch unser Beitrag für die
Gesellschaft den wir leisten sollten und
deswegen selbst in Bayern ist Abfall ich
habe möchte ich noch mal die
Eigenverantwortung appellieren auch wenn
Sie eher mäßig klappt in Deutschland
aber wir können nicht auf der einen
Seite klagen über die Kinderkliniken
dass sie überschwemmt werden auf der
anderen Seite solche Maßnahmen
zurücknehmen und auch in dem Wissen dass
es uns alle nervt aber ich glaube wir
sind daraufhin wirklich guten Weg jetzt
der Pandemie wir sind wirklich gut dabei
wir sind gut vorbereitet gewesen die
Pandemie läuft langsam aus das heißt wir
müssen noch ein bisschen durchhalten und
sollten vielleicht gerade die Kinder
Klienten im
wirklichen Auge behalten und was
sicherlich noch mal ganz wertvoller
Bestandteil auch unseres Konzeptes ist
dass wir die Möglichkeit öffnen das
Kinderkliniken mehr Geld bekommt ja oder
generell die Kinder und Jugendmedizin
das wird in der Zukunft helfen dass in
den Kinderkliniken auch vielleicht nicht
Pflegefachpersonen angestellt werden
können aber andere die dann sofortiv
helfen den Klinikalltag gut zu managen
das sind ganz wichtiger Bestandteil auch
unseres Konzeptes die letzte Frage für
heute hat der Rödel aber vielen Dank
[Musik]
eine Frage zur grenzüberschreitenden
medizinischen Versorgung in
Grenzregionen wie dem Saarland der
spielt die Grenze eigentlich keine große
Rolle mehr man arbeitet in Frankreich
man lebt in Deutschland oder andersrum
und deswegen wächst der unmotor hier aus
Unverständnis darüber dass eben bei der
medizinischen Versorgung eben doch noch
eine harte Grenze in ganz vielen Fällen
da ist also ein französischer Patient
der direkt hinter der Grenze wohnt muss
60 Kilometer nach Metz fahren zur
Chemotherapie andererseits könnten
deutsche Patienten in bei französischen
Ärzten schneller Termine kriegen der
Fachärzten auch das passiert nicht man
kann das deutsche Gesundheitssystem ja
auch entlasten darüber warum kriegt man
da keine praxisnah keine praktikable
Lösung kennen in den Grenzregion
ja vielen Dank dass ihr wichtige Frage
zumal die unterschiedlichen
Abrechnungssysteme und zum zweiten wer
ist wo versichert und hier ist es
tatsächlich auch also aus meiner Sicht
an den Ländern die betroffen sind mit
den Krankenkassen zusammen
Finanzierungsmodelle zu entwickeln also
wenn die Länder und die Krankenkassen
sich zum Beispiel einigen würden das
bestimmte Leistungen aus dem Ausland
auch erbracht werden können das wird
vergüten nach bestimmten Regeln dann
käme man ein ganzes Stück weiter ich
kenne das von einzelnen Kliniken das tun
zum Beispiel das Aachener Klinikum macht
das also mit den Anbietern in den
Niederlanden zusammen und dort sind die
Kassen aktiv das also auch von Land zu
Land unterschiedlich aber wie gesagt die
Länder sind dort in der Pflicht wir
können das als Bund nicht regeln es wäre
aber hoch wünschenswert
dann bedanke ich mich Herr Minister Frau
Bürger meine Herren und wünsche einen
schönen Tag